well hello there
welcome to this series where we make
this beautiful simple application that
you see right here that is uh akin to
like a facebook or a twitter or any
social media application where we allow
the users to register or log in after
they register and then create and share
posts with other users and interact with
the with those posts and those other
users so if i were to demonstrate this
app right now
we could go to the register page which
you see right here that shows us this
form and if click on register you can
see that we're going to be implementing
validation so that's going to be done on
the server side and represented on the
client side as you see right here and i
already registered so i can straight
away go to login and have a user called
user
with a password of one through six so i
hit enter and it logs me in and now i
can have this form right here which
allows me to submit a new post so i'm
gonna do that
here is
my new post i hit enter and it
immediately shows here and there's like
a really simple slick animation that
fades in
like i said we can interact with these
posts so for example i can like this
post here and the in
increments instantly and it changes
color i can as well comment on it so i
go here and i'll say
yeah it's the new thing
and i hit enter and it's posted and as
you see anything that is posted by our
own user will have this delete button
right here which
in this case is the delete comment and
if i go back it's a delete post and if
you click it it shows you this uh
confirm model you click ok and indeed
that post is gone
so this application uses uh react on the
front end
so this is something that i hope you're
at least a little bit familiar with if
not it's okay this is a
beginner-friendly series i'm gonna go
through every uh single thing that i use
and explain it why i'm writing it in
that way
so alongside of react on the front end
we're gonna be using semantic ui to
style it and give it this very simple
but still elegant uh style uh if you
used something like bootstrap before
you're gonna feel very comfortable using
this it's a very similar kind of uh
approach to the uh to styling but it has
some extra elements and uh some
simplicity to it and that's why i chose
it for this series
and uh in terms of the focus of the
series it's going to be on graphql which
is a query language that sits as an
interface between our application and
the server and the database and i'm
going to explain in a little bit more
about graphql so stick around for that
[Music]
but what is graphql well i'm glad you
asked graphql is a query language that
we can use as part of our server-side
code and it sits on our existing api
graphql is technology agnostic meaning
that it doesn't care what programming
language or database you're using
whether your api is some code that
fetches and writes data on a database or
it's code that consumes another api and
gets data from there as long as you
shape the data properly according to
type definitions defined by you
it will receive and send data to the web
client without any problems
there are three types of graphql
operations that we can perform
queries for reading data for example
fetching one or multiple posts and
mutations for writing data which
includes creating updating and deleting
examples of this would be
creating a post updating user details or
deleting a comment um or deleting a like
and subscriptions for listening to
changes in our data in real real time
this is done using websockets in the
background and it's useful for things
like chat or polling apps mostly you'll
use queries and mutations
when using graphql whether reading or
writing data we always send a post
request with a body that contains some
information about what type of data that
we want to get back or save on the
database
rest apis were created to have a
conventional way of sending and
receiving data between the client and
the server but even though these
conventions make rest apis easier to
deal with there can be different types
of resources and there can be different
endpoint names and endpoint parameter
variables etc
graphql reduces the amount of
information needed for developers to
learn how to consume an api by having
one main endpoint fewer operations and
self-documenting apis
this will become clearer as we start to
implement it
a lot of companies like facebook twitter
paypal and many more are now using
graphql in some of their services to
benefit from the improvements that it
offers over a traditional rest api
the major advantage of using graphql is
the control over the amount of data
requested and sent back to the client
let's send let's say for example in our
home page of our app we want to fetch
recent posts and we want to show a
couple of things about them like
timestamps body username and number of
likes and comments
using rest api we would send a request
and get an array of posts each one
looking like this
and then display the details that we
want and ignore the rest of the data
that we don't need
this isn't strictly speaking a problem
but because in this example we don't
need the comments and likes themselves
just the number of them it would be
better if we were to receive something
like this
by reducing the amount of data sent back
from the server we decrease bandwidth
usage and latency time
we could actually do this by adding
another endpoint that returns just that
data and use that on the home page but
this becomes a problem as we find
ourselves writing more endpoints the
more pages we have and which will
drastically increase the amount of code
that we have to write on the back end
and we have to document all of these
endpoints for our front-end developers
or for anyone consuming this api you can
now see why this approach isn't optimal
graphql solves this by letting us send a
post request to one endpoint and specify
what resource we want in this case posts
and what fields we want in this case
everything except likes and comments we
can also specify many more factors like
what post uh what the post body contains
if we were for example to search for a
specific post
or post by a certain user
or a specific number of posts etc
all of these can be done through one
single endpoint and just by changing the
request body itself
so
these are the tech that we're going to
be using for this series
basically mern plus graphql well mern if
you will
will use apollo server which uses an
express server in the background or you
can also use something like express
graphql or graphql yoga they all do the
job well but i personally prefer the
tools that come shipped with apollo
server
like i mentioned this series will be a
standalone and right after the series
we'll implement the front end using
react with hooks and context api and
we'll use apollo clients there and the
new apollo react hooks library to make
sure that we write our app using the
most up-to-date features of the
frameworks that we're using so i wanted
to do a demonstration of the server that
we're going to be building so this is
our server application running at port
5000 uh you can have it at slash
graphql or you can have it just at the
base url it doesn't make a difference um
so this is the graphql playground and
one of the tools that we get from apollo
server and here i wanted to show you
some examples from our application that
we'll build
so this is an example of a query so
right here you specify the type of
operation in this case it's a query and
then you specify the name of the query
that we want to use depending on the
type definitions that you have so i've
already written this query get posts
which returns us just that the posts
from our database
and here we specify the fields from that
query that we want and these are of
course defined as well in our type
definitions that what each resource
returns in terms of fields
and if i press the play button here it's
actually going to fetch from our
database our data and returns it in a in
this object inside of this data inside
of this get posts object so each time we
send a query our result is sent back in
a object that has the same name as that
query unless we have some errors and
then we will get an object um errors
right here and then we'll have our
errors there so here as you can see we
get exactly the data that we asked for
id body all the way through a comment
count and here to demonstrate to you the
flexibility of
graphql we can say just let's just get
the id and the body and if we press play
we get exactly that data so bear in mind
that this is on the server right now
that means
none of this data has been sent to the
client so the server gets this request
and then on the server decides what data
to fetch it fetches all of the data from
the database and then it filters out the
data that the user didn't ask for and
then returns a smaller payload of data
so here if you want to add more fields
we can actually do control space and
this tool self documents and it fetches
automatically our types and knows what
to expect so here if we forgot our
fields we can just do
control space and then click on create
that and if i want to get the username
now i add these two and i hit enter and
we get those fields now as well
now this tool is available for your
front-end developer once you expose this
once you deploy this app and you give
this base url which will be something
other than localhost if you deploy it
live
your front-end developer will have
access to this tool and then we'll learn
how your api works your graphql api
works without you having to write any
documentation they can just click on the
schema tab and they will see all the
queries and mutations available for
example if they want to see how the get
get posts query works they can click on
it and they will see the type and the
type of data each of the fields have and
they will learn how to actually interact
with your api without you having to
write any documentation this is what i
mentioned earlier by graphql being
self-documenting now let's look at
mutations so let me close this if we go
here i've already written these two
mutations for login and register
if i were to run the login user or pass
it of course i've already written the
code for this saying that look at the
login requires a username and a password
and returns a couple of things one of
them is a json web token that we will
use on our client to
authenticate the user and keep them
authenticated for a period of time if i
click here and i click on the login user
um mutation there we go we get our token
back which we will use later to
access protected routes like creating
posts or liking or commenting on posts
and
i've already like as well
thought about validation and server
validation which is an important thing
for us to learn to validate the data and
for example as we see here we already
have a user with the username user if we
were to try to register another user
with that username and click here on
register user we get errors and we get
as well an array of errors right here
and saying confirm password passwords
must match actually it validated the
passwords before the user
if i were to put two matching passwords
it will still have an error saying that
the username is taken because it is
taken and now if i solve all the uh the
errors let's say user to which doesn't
exist on our database and we say the
email um well i set it up to be jane so
i was meant to type jane here as a
username and this should go through and
we're requesting more fields than just
the token and we click
here register and there we go we get all
the details back of from our user table
record and we can use this on the client
to authenticate and send protected route
requests so yeah
and by the way i didn't mean protected
route and then protected operations
since there's only one route when using
graphql so i just wanted to demonstrate
quickly our app and yeah this is of
course we have more mutations and
queries to build once we start building
this app
i hope that this gave you a clear
understanding of what graphql is and
that you're excited for building this
project i know i'm excited about
releasing this series thank you for
watching and will see you in the next
video cheers
all right welcome to the first class of
this series
uh i decided to call them classes
because lesson is way overused someone
beat me to that and
to be honest it sounds boring i wouldn't
use lesson and video it's like
everything is a video so i had to stand
out okay
all right enough of that
now that you know what this project is
about and what technology that we're
going to use and why we're going to use
it let's actually start to set up our
development environment
just to make sure to be on the safe side
make sure you have node installed and
npm i'm pretty sure you have it if you
don't go to nodejs.org and download the
latest stable version or the current one
to make sure that you have it open up a
terminal window and do node v
and i have it i have 10 15 3 whatever
and do mpm-v to make sure that you have
npm installed
all right other than node
we're going to use mongodb atlas which
is a cool service by mongodb which lets
us create
one free cluster
just because it's one it doesn't mean
we're limited we can have as many
databases and collections within that
one cluster so yeah we're going to use
this so go to mongodb.com and let's go
to try free sign up for an account if
you don't have one
i'll sign up for one here as well so
put my email
my name
misspelled my own name
for the
password and that's okay we need to
agree guys
all right let's create an account
alright asks us to set up a couple of
things
i'll say i'm learning mongodb
i'll select aws and select the uh the
one that's nearest to you i'll select
okay i don't have three tier in london
so i'll select the ireland one if you're
in america you're probably gonna select
north virginia or or origin oregon i
don't know what that is
sorry americans i don't know what that
reads like all right so
make sure that you select stuff that's
just the free tier you can sign up of
course for a paid account it's based on
uh it's hosted with aws so the
performance will be great
so cluster name
i'm just going to give it cluster 0
that's fine i'll just say create cluster
and there we go my cluster has been or
is being created um
while it creates let's create a user
that we can use to connect to this
cluster and edit databases and stuff
like that so here let's go to security
and then go to
add new user here i'll give it a
username say
just classed like this
and i'll have it auto generate a
password actually i want to see that
password because i'm going to need it
and let's say add user
make sure that your user
if you want you can as well customize
the role what
what type of permissions they get read
and write any database is okay for me
but if you want to just lock it down to
a specific database know that you can do
that as well
all right so one more thing that we need
to do is go to ipwhitelist we need to as
well give
a certain ip address that we allow that
ip address to connect to our database
otherwise no machine is able to connect
to this database so go to security
ipwhitelist and go here add ip
address you can add your current machine
ip but i find the problem with this is
that sometimes your ip changes and you
fail to connect to it and you find
yourself coming back to this
dashboard and adding a new ip so as a
just because we're in development i'm
gonna click here allow access from
anywhere which will allow any machine to
connect to this cluster
but in production of course that's not a
good idea you only want your server to
access your database all right so our
cluster is still being created so i'll
be back once this is done
[Music]
okay so our cluster has now been created
uh let's leave it like that for now
i'm gonna go to the desktop let's create
our project i'm just going to create a
folder here
i'll call it merge
like this and open it using vs code
and here i'll open up the terminal
window
uh when i create
uh actually we need to initialize an npm
project so let's do npm init i'm just
going to do dash y but you can as well
write any details that you want i'm just
going to leave it right like that
i'm going to create two files
so here i'll create an index.js and i'll
create a dot get ignore
file
and by the way i'm going to initialize a
get repository here
and i'm going to have the pro the files
for this project are going to be in a
repository depending on whether i've
finished the whole project and uploaded
it on the github or not there will be a
link in the description which is with
each
part of the video each class in its own
branch so for example this would be
class one and it will have the complete
code for this
class for this video all right so let me
close this actually we need to install
some dependencies so here we'll say npm
install
and we will need apollo server
and graphql
and mongoose that we will use to connect
to our database so let's leave that to
install i'll go to the index.js
here i'll bring the apollo server so
i'll say const apollo
server
equals require
and i'll require apollo
server like this which hasn't been
installed but that's fine
and here
the thing is we need to have something
called type definitions
we'll say const
type
usually referred to as type defs like
this
and
for this we need uh something called gql
we can import that say const gql
not from equals require
and here we'll get it from something
called graphql tag which is one of the
the dependencies of apollo server so
that's installed with apollo server here
we'll say gql
um and do backticks like this which is a
tag template string and here we will
write our types our graphql types
and
here we will start with type query
and by the way to get um to get syntax
highlighting inside of this ticks
you need to install something called
where is it it's right here graphql for
vs code so this will have synth will
allow you to have syntax highlighting
inside of these backticks for graphql
all right so here we'll have type query
and inside of our types
when we have the type query inside of
here we will have all of our queries set
them up and say what type they return so
one of the queries that we're going to
have just to test it out i'll call this
say hi
and it will return so
kind of like typescript if you've used
we need to say a return type for this it
will return a string
and we can add an exclamation mark to it
that means it's required it has to
return a string or we can leave it like
that
it's always better to have the required
fields as required so you know you will
have more type safety
all right so
here we need as well something else
called resolvers so we'll say cost
resolvers
and what resolvers do is for each query
or mutation or subscription it has its
corresponding
resolver so if this query is called say
hi it needs a resolver called say hi
which processes some sort of logic and
then returns what this query returns so
here
we will say query again
because we need to group all of our
queries inside the query object and all
of our mutations inside the mutation
object so here we'll say query and we
only have one right now which is this
say hi so we can say say hi
as a function and here we need to return
we can have as well we can have it as an
arrow function i think and for this it's
simple enough to just have it as an
arrow function so here this will just
return
or actually we don't need to the return
keyword here it will just return
hello
world
like this
now we need to set up our apollo server
actually let me close that here i'll say
const server
equals
new
apollo
server
and this takes two options for now the
type definitions so you you see there is
an option called typedefs and i can say
the typedef is our typedefs but since
this is es6 we don't need to do that it
infers on its own if the
key and the value are the same it will
take that
so and we have as well the resolvers
which are called resolvers so this will
do like this all right so now that we
have our
server instance we can actually start
our server so we can say server
dot listen
and we can leave it like that or we can
specify a port i'll specify a port and
i'll say
5000 and this returns a promise so we
need to say that then and we get a
result object
and there are a couple of things in this
result object but we're not going to
need them we only need one just um i'll
show you so i'll say console.log once
the server starts
and i'll do backticks and say server
running at and an injector variable here
a template variable we say result or res
dot url so this will log it to the
console so that we can control click it
and open our server
all right uh like i told you just to
show you
that apollo server actually if you open
your node modules and you go down here
you'll see that express is installed
it's only running an express server in
the back we're not going to write any
specific express routes but just to show
you that it's actually using express uh
in
in the you know behind the scenes all
right so here we can say node oops node
index to run our index file
and there we go we get server running at
localhost 5000 and if we go to our
um
to our
actually not 8000 we need to go to 5000
localhost 5000 there we go we get our
graphql playground
here we can say query to test out the
query that we created we can do control
space and it will tell us all the
queries that we have right now which are
just the say hi right now and you can
also go to the schema and it will tell
you what queries and mutations and
subscriptions that you have obviously we
have the just the one right now and of
course you can go and it will tell you
that this
returns a string and explains what the
string is of course you don't need that
alright so here we can press play and
there we go we get hello world simple as
that and if we change it or like we can
say hello world with a couple of
exclamation marks we save and we stop
and run the server again node index
and we go back and we do control by the
way you can do control enter to execute
it and there we go we get this has
changed now all right so let's actually
connect to our database
for this we're gonna need mongoose so
here let's say const mongoose
equals require
mongoose so mongoose is the
orm library object relational mapper
which lets us interface with the mongodb
database that we have
so here
at the bottom actually we need to
connect to the database before we start
our server so let's do here
mongoose.connect
and for us to connect we need an actual
connection string and we can get that
from our
mongodb
atlas
dashboard so here we go to connect
and do i have that password still in the
clipboard i do call actually i need that
password that i copied from earlier
so i'm just going to paste it here
and then i'll go back go to connect
again and go to connect your application
and grab this connection string so click
copy here
and it's better practice that you put
these
sensitive key data in their own file so
here i'll create the file call it config
click on gig
config.js
and here i'll say module.exports
equals and i'll export an object i'll
have a key [ __ ]
db
and this will hold the connection string
so i'll do a string and paste that
and here instead of this tag password i
need my actual password so i'll cut that
from there and put it instead of this
password so that's my user that's the
password that's the cluster
the cluster address so we can connect to
it
and i'll go to the get ignore and
of course we need to remove the node
modules
so that it doesn't track that and we
need to remove as well the
config.js so that if we push this code
to a github repository or
any or bitbucket or whatever we don't
actually push this because this is
sensitive data
all right so let's save all files and
here in the mongoose connect we need to
bring that mongodb connection string so
here we'll say const
[ __ ] or actually we need to destructure
it
[ __ ]
db
equals require
so from the same directory
config.js like this
all right so now that we have that
string
inside of here we need to say mongodb
like that
and
here we need to pass some an object some
options we only need this uh use new url
parser otherwise it's going to give us
some deprecation warning if we don't and
this returns a promise so we need to say
dot then
and we don't need the result there's
nothing there but then we actually do
this
server.listen
so here we need to say return
server.listen like this and import 5000
and then we need to as well chain this
dot then to the end of this
and then
everything will run the same but except
now it will actually connect to the
database
let's actually as well log something
from here to just show that we've
connected to the database successfully
so i'll say console.log
mongodb connected
like this
let's save uh stop this development
server and say node index again
all right so i get an error
can't find module config.js
oh because
here it's an actual file and not a
dependency
so here i'll say node index again
and there we go get no mongodb connected
and server running at 5000. of course
right now we're not doing anything to
the database so we we're just connected
without performing any operations all
right so what i want to start to do now
is to create the database models so that
we can use them to interface with the
database with so here i'll create a
folder called models
and inside of here i'll create the user
model so user with a capital u dot js
and this will hold
details about the schema
mongodb is schema-less but with mongoose
we can specify a schema to have more
safety when working with our server code
so here i'll
bring two things from
mongoose so const and this structure
model and schema with a capital s
like this
let's say equals require
mongoose
here i'll say const
user
schema
equals
i'll say new schema
and here we'll pass it the fields
and our user will have a username which
will be unique to each user and here
i'll say string now we could say on each
entry that it's a string and it's
required we could specify it here but
because we're using graphql as a
middleman we can use graphql itself to
say that these fields are required or
not so we will handle that on the
graphql layer and not the mongoose layer
so here we'll have a password for our
user it's going to be a string as well
we're going to have a username actually
we've had the username i'm going to have
an email
it's going to be a string
and a created ad which is i'm going to
store it as a string you can store it as
a date it doesn't make a difference as
long as your code works well with it so
here we'll say module.export and we need
to export our model so module.exports
equals
model we need to call the model pass it
a name so the name of our model will be
user with a capital u and the schema it
uses is going to be the user schema
all right so now we're going to create
another model for the post so we'll say
post.js
and here we'll
bring the same stuff the model and the
schema so we can copy that paste it here
and we'll say const
post schema equals
new schema
and we'll pass it a couple of things
each post will have a body which is
going to be a
string and we'll have a username so who
posted this which is going to be a
string as well it's going to be the
user's username it will have a created
ad
which is going to be a string now we can
as well specify a default value for the
created at here but we will do that on
the graphql resolvers i prefer to do
that on the graphql resolvers
so here each post could have as well an
array of comments
so here we'll say comments
and do like this square brackets as an
array and here do curly braces to have
an object and each comment will have a
body so this will be a string it will
have a username so who posted this
and this will be a string as well
and a created add
a string as well
so after comments we'll have likes
it's going to be an array
and we could just have user names but
you could um it's better to give them a
created at as well
so that you can have some you know you
can have some analytics on your
application and know what's going on and
when likes are being submitted and all
of that good stuff all right so i'll
give it a creator that which is going to
be a string and
even though that mongodb like i said is
a
schema less and it's a nosql so there's
it's not uh doesn't have relations but
the rm itself lets us have relations
between our models now we don't have to
do this but you could link your data
models so i could as well say user here
and link it to a specific user this post
and then here we can say type
this is going to be referred to another
schema object so we'll say schema dot
types like this dot
object
id
and here we'll say ref and we'll pass it
the table or the collection which is
users so this allows us to later use
mongoose to
automatically populate this user field
if we want using some mongoose methods
all right so
here we need to export this so we say
module.exports equals model
again we give the name of the model
which is post
and we give the schema which is going to
be
post
schema
all right
now let's go back to our index let's
import our post model so here we'll say
const post
equals
uh why i'm separating these because it's
it's just general convention that you
keep your relative imports here and then
your dependency imports up here so here
i'll say require
and
go to the models folder models oops
models slash
post
so now that we have the model
uh what i want to do now is i want to
create a query for fetching all the
posts from the database
i'll actually get rid of this say hi and
say get posts here
so this get post will get all the posts
from our database and it's going to go
to the collection
posts and bring all the documents from
there and return them back to our user
but before that actually i want to
create a post on our database so that we
can fetch because there isn't any right
now so let's go to our cluster
and let's go to collections
so here we have no collection right now
let's click on add my own data let's
create a database i'll just call this
merg
and
collection we're just going to create
the first collection call it posts let's
click create
let's insert a dummy document here
it's going to give an automatic id here
i'm going to give it a field body
and this will say
this is a sample post
and i'm gonna give it
i'm gonna give it another another field
click this uh add this plus button here
i'll give it a user
name and this will say user
click the plus button again and give it
a created oops
created
add
just give it some gibberish it's just a
string after all we're gonna later have
our code create these instead of just
create them manually of course
actually i'm just going to leave it like
that say insert
all right now that we have our document
let's actually fetch it let's go to our
code here our get posts let me close
this terminal uh our get posts is going
to return a type of uh post so it's
going to return an array of posts so we
do these
square brackets and say post which is a
graphql type that we haven't created yet
so let's create that we will say our
post so type post will have a couple of
fields so we'll have an id it's going to
be of type id like this and we put an
exclamation mark saying that this is
required we need to have it you will
have a body
of type string and it's going to be
required you have a created ad
a required string as well
we'll have a username oops
username
of type string
and you will have
actually i'm just going to leave
let's forget about comments and likes
for now and let's keep it like that and
here for our query so we have um get
posts let's actually create a resolver
for it i'm going to get rid of that say
hi we don't need that anymore i'll say
get posts
and as a function like this
and here we need to use our post model
to fetch these posts
so actually i'm going to use async await
syntax so i'll add the keyword async
before this
function
and here i'll say try because the thing
is is like maybe your query will never
fail but if you don't do this if you if
your query fails it might stop your
actual server which is not good so here
we'll say const posts so let's first
choose both we'll say await because this
is an async operation post our model
dot find
and uh so yeah this is it it's don't
find if you don't specify any uh
condition it's gonna find all of them
it's gonna fetch all of them so here
we're just going to say return posts
and here we'll say catch
if we get any error we'll say throw
new
error
and we pass it that error
all right this should do let's save all
files make sure you save all files
and let's stop our server and start it
again say node index
all right it runs without any errors and
we go to our local host 5000
you can press this refresh sometimes you
need to refresh it to get the new
queries and here it's it's having error
because this query doesn't exist anymore
so we can use the other query which is
get posts and it gives us some
intellisense so we need to open these
curly braces and specify which fields we
want so here if we press control space
it tells us that we can get these fields
which is exactly like the type that we
defined so let's actually get all of
these fields so
select all of them body what else do we
have created add and the username
and let's click control enter
and we get an empty array
all right let's check our code
interesting let's check our database
oh okay i know why
my bad i forgot something so let's go to
our config right here it says test but
this is actually the database name we
need to give the database name uh the db
name is merg
it's and it's not test and by the way
even if you don't have a database on
atlas and you just give a name here and
you perform
persistence like you create
a document it's actually going to create
this database if you have the
permissions for it so i'm going to stop
the server and run it again and this
time it should work
all right let's go and let's run the
same query and there we go i get the
post that we just created and yeah so
the query is working all right so this
is it for this video
hey
welcome back to class number two
all right you might have heard the terms
ui and ux and those have to be good in
your application but have you heard this
term called dx let me know in the
comments if you have if you haven't dx
is developer experience
and right now we don't have a really
good one
because
a
our type type definitions are all in the
index and these will grow bigger and our
resolvers as well are an index and each
time we have to restart our server we
have to do it manually let's fix these
before we dive into more functionality
so these type devs will be in their own
file so here i'll create a folder called
graphql
and here i'll create a file called type
defs
dot js
so here i'm going to cut these typedefs
paste them here
we need to bring gql so we're going to
say const
gql
equals require
you can import it from apollo server as
well because graphql tag is just a
subdependency of that as well and we
need to export this so we'll say module
dot exports
equals gql blah blah blah
all right so here we need to import
those so here we'll say cons
type defs
equals require
and we require what is it
graphql slash type defs
and the resolvers as well and for the
resolvers i'm going to divide them
we're going to have the resolvers for
posts in their own file and resolvers
for
users in their own file as well because
otherwise we're going to have one
massive file with all the resolvers so
here i'll create a folder called
resolvers
i've said resolvers like 10 times
resolvers resolves
i'll create an index js and i'll come
back to this
and here i'll create a post
dot js
and uses
js
and let's go back to our index so here
let's cut this actually let's just cut
this
or just this query
remove this
and here in the where is it the post
let's say module oops module dot exports
equals this object and it's going to
have a query actually no we copied the
query we just paste that in
we need the post module or mod model so
we'll say const post
equals require
uh we go back one level actually we go
back two levels to model slash
post
all right
and
we need a way to combine all these
resolvers so here in the index
we want to import that
post resolver so we'll say
const
of course it's the default um export so
we can name it anything so we'll call
them
posts resolvers
solvers like this
all right here we get them from the same
directory posts
and uh let's import the uh
the user's resolvers as well while we're
here resolvers
even though it's empty right now
so we'll save from users
and here we'll uh export
this um object so let's say
module.exports so this object will
combine both of them we'll say query
for now we have just query from post
resolvers so we'll say we'll do the
spread operator
posts resolvers dot query
and here we'll say mutation actually we
don't have any mutations right now we'll
just leave it like that
and because right now we only have this
one query
all right so
now our type devs are there
and um
our
resolvers are there so we need to import
these resolvers
so we don't need this post model anymore
we can get rid of that and say const
resolvers
equals require
and we say slash graphql slash resolvers
because uh it's in the index we don't
need to say anything more
and the names are still the same so
everything should work the same we don't
need gql anymore here
and let's save everything
let's stop the development server and
actually
now i want to install nodemon you
probably have heard of this
module or a library if you haven't it's
just something that starts a node
application and whenever we change any
file within this directory it restarts
the server for us
so i'm going to say mpm oops
npm install dash capital d as a so it
installs as a dev dependency and say
nodemon
and here i'll write the script for it so
i'll say the script start will say
nodemon
index.js
or we can just say index
all right i'll save that i'll wait for
it to finish okay now that it's done we
can just say npm start
all right it started then let's test out
our query
all right oh it's so instant that i
think that it's not actually sending it
let me make sure
yeah okay it is sending that query all
right so everything is working the same
now we can uh get going with the rest of
the functionality so before implementing
the rest of the crud functionalities on
our posts like creating posts and
editing them or deleting them let's
actually create ways for our users to
authenticate because the create and
delete posts
actions or resolvers
have to be from protected user or
authenticated users so let's actually
start with registering users so first
thing is we add an actual query for or
mutation for that so here we'll say
mutation or type
mutation
because this is making a change in our
database so here we'll say register
and
here we can have
input from our users as arguments and
take that and do stuff with it in our
business logic so here we can say that
we can take a username a password a
confirm password and email but we can
create a type for that as well if we
don't want this to be a massive line
here so i'll say register
input like this of type
register
uh register oops no register input with
a capital r like this and i'll create
that type here so i'll say
and this is not a type this is an input
which is a different
type of type which is given as an input
to um to a resolver
for it to return something for us so
here i'll say type
register
oops
register input
and this will have the four fields so
username
type string is going to be required a
password
type string required again
a confirm password
because again this is for the register
form so we need two uh the confirm
passwords as well so and we need the
email as well we'll say string and it's
required
all right and this needs to return
something so it will return a type user
so let's create this user and it's
required so let's say type
user
and this will have an id of type id
and it will have an email
type string
and by the way even if we specify
required it doesn't mean that the user
has to get these you know this that
means we have to return them from our
resolver but the user can still opt out
from not getting these
so
it will return an authentication token
and it will return what else the
username of the user
which is a string
and the created at
all right so let's actually implement
this resolver for this register
and here i'll go here actually here
let's add a mutation field mutation
and this will take
from the user's resolver
that mutation object which we haven't
created yet but we will so let's save
this and close it
let's go to our users here we'll need
our user mongoose model so we say const
user equals require
and we go back two levels to models
models slash user
and here we'll say module dot
exports
and we'll export this object and for now
we'll have a mutation
and here we need to implement our
resolver for the register so we'll say
register
and now this needs to take some input
and we have four things that we can
get in our
resolver arguments so the first will be
parent i'll explain these in a second
the second is args arguments
the third will be context and the fourth
will be info
most of the time we'll just be using
args
but parent
is it it gives you the result of what
was the input from the last step but
here it will be undefined because there
is no there was no step before this but
in some cases you could have multiple
resolvers so data goes from one resolver
and then it goes to the other and then
it goes to the other and then
it gets processed in different ways and
then returned to the user but here we
don't need it so we can just say um
underscore like this so it doesn't you
know take up any space
so arguments here this is these
arguments from here it's this register
input so args right now for this
resolver will have a register input and
inside of that we'll have these four
fields
and here we have context which i'll
explain later you'll see what this does
and info just has some general
information about um some metadata that
we actually almost never need all right
so here inside of here we're gonna have
a couple of steps what we need to do i'm
gonna put a couple of to do's and come
back to them so the first thing is we
need to validate the data so let's say
validate user data
and this means like we could have empty
fields so we need to make sure to to
have server validation in case we have
some problems like passwords don't match
email already exists etc
in our case emails are not um
unique but usernames are so we need to
check for that
so we will do a special check for that
because we need to check in our database
so here we'll say
make sure
user
doesn't
already exist
and then the first step will be to
the hash the password before we store it
in our database of course
and create an authentication token so an
auth token
all right so we will skip the validation
for now we'll come back to it later and
let's first hash the password and return
the data to our user for this we're
going to install two packages so i'll
say npm install
first will be b crypt
bcrib js
and json web token
so bcrypt will help us script the
password and json web token will help us
encrypt encode some data in a token and
return it to our user
so here we need to get that data that
the user sent we can destructure it here
but we can as well do it here i prefer
this structuring from here so here we
can say curly braces to destructure from
the args and we need to further
destructure the register input so we'll
say register input colon and here we'll
get our fields so we'll have our
username
we have an email
the password
oops password
and the confirm password
like this let prettier format it and now
we have access to these four fields
separately
so here we'll say
we'll edit the password we'll change the
value to it to the hashed password so
we'll say await
because
the bcrypt function the hashing function
is actually asynchronous so we need to
add as well the async keyword here to
the function and we'll say await
bcrypt actually we need to import it
let's import both right now so we'll say
const be
crypt equals require
b crypt
js
and we'll get
the json web token so we'll say cons jwt
equals require
json web
token all right
so here we'll say
and weight b
crypt dot hash
and this will take the password
and it will ask us for the number of
rounds usually 12 is a good number based
on what i've seen so
const here we want to form our
user object so we'll say const new user
equals and we'll call new
user
our model and we'll pass it the data
that we have so the email will be email
so we don't need to say email
username
oops user name
and the password
as well will be password so we keep
these fields like that and we need to
have a created at so this will be new
date
and we need to change the
to iso string method to convert it to a
string
so here we'll say const result equals
await
a new user dot save
to the database
and now we need to return this data to
the user but before that we need to
actually create a token for our user so
here we'll say const token
token
equals
jwt dot sign
and this will take some data like a
payload to put inside the token and we
want to encode the id so this will be
result.id
i want to encode the email this will be
result.email
and the username as well
so res.username
and uh
here let's um we need to give it a
secret
and let's actually store this secret in
the config file as well so we don't have
it in our um
in a git repository we don't make a
mistake by sharing it with people so i'm
going to import it before creating it
i'll say const
secret
key
like this equals require
we go back two levels to the config file
and let's go to that config file and
create
an entry here
and say
secret oops
secret
key
equals some
very
secret key i don't know it doesn't
matter this will be used as the um key
to encrypt your uh
encode your uh token so
only our server will be able to decode
this stuff
here i'll give an array of options and
actually here the secret goes here so
secret key and the third parameter will
be some options and i only need the
option of expires in
to give it a an expiration
time which is going to be 1h for one
hour so now let's say return
here we want to spread the data of our
user so we'll say
spread res dot
underscore doc where our document is
stored i want to give the id because
it's not by default in a doc so we'll
say res id equals rest dot
underscore id
and we want to give the token as well
so let's save all of this and see if
this is working
let's go to our app
and here we can say
mutation
we can actually do this in a new tab
same mutation
and this will be register
and we'll take a register input
which is going to be this object that
will have a username
oops
use the name
of user
i have a password of
one two three
through six
a confirmed password
of
one through six and an email of
user
email.com
let's send this oh actually we need to
get some fields back so let's open curly
braces and let's
let's get all of them so the id
email
token uh what is it um
username
and what else the created ad right let's
send this
there we go we get our id email
everything our authentication token and
if we look at our database and we
refresh
we see this
user's collection was created and it's
got one document which has the details
for our user cool so we're now
successfully registering users
but of course right now if we send this
request it will register another user
with the same username of course we
don't want that so let's actually make
make sure that this doesn't happen so
let's go to our app
right here we need to get a user so um
so this is done so we can remove this to
do and by the way you can get this
to do what is it to do highlight
extension to have this um highlight that
all right so here we'll say const user
construct
user equals
user dot find oops
find
one
and here we need to pass a filter or a
condition and this condition will be the
username has to be like the username so
we can just pass it like this
and of course this is asynchronous so we
need to say wait and here we'll say if
user
so if there is a user this is not going
to be null if not it's going to be null
so if user then we need to return an
error because user already exists uh we
can just say throw error but we can as
well use specific errors from apollo so
we we can import those so we say import
i'm going to import the user
input
error
this will become useful when we uh
it's because later apollo client will be
able to recognize the type of error and
handle it differently so here we'll say
require
apollo server
and here we'll throw we'll say
throw
new oops
throw new
what is a user
bad input or input error and this will
say username
is taken
and actually we're going to pass a
payload for with our errors that we will
use as well on the client so the payload
will have an errors object and inside of
here it will have a username key and
this will say this username is taken
this
errors object will be used later on our
front end to
display these errors on on the form
and actually right here this info and
context we're not using them so we can
just omit them we we still have to say
to use the parent one to have the access
to the args
all right let's save this
and let's check on our
playground and let's send this request
and there we go it says username is
taken and if i do another username say
john
um we can keep everything else the same
and we send i actually registered john
and if i send again it doesn't register
john because that username is taken all
right let's now implement some
validation as well because right now if
we just submit some empty fields it's
still gonna register the you know a user
with an empty username and all that
stuff of course we don't want that so
let's go here
let's create a folder here called util
for utilities and i'm going to create a
file inside of it called validate
validators
oops validators dot js
and here i'll import
a function so here we'll say
module.exports or export rather and here
i'll call it validate
register
oops
register
input
and this will take the four fields so
username
email
password
confirm password
and that's it and they will um do okay
this i said this to be an arrow function
so i'll do this
and so here we'll do const errors
equals an empty object for now
and we'll say if
username
dot trim
equals
an empty string so if username is empty
we'll say errors dot username
equals
username
must not be empty
[Music]
here let's copy this
let's do the same thing for email so
ctrl d here and say email so if email is
empty we'll say email must not must not
be empty but as well even if email is
not empty we need to check if it's a
valid email so here i'll say const
regex and i'm gonna match this string to
a regular expression that checks that
this
string is an email i'm going to put this
in this description you'll find this in
the description so now i'm just going to
paste it in and here i'll say
if
not email dot match
and we pass this regex
so if it doesn't match this regular
expression that means it's not it's not
in a format it's not in a pattern of an
email so we'll say actually not errors
errors dot email equals
email
must be a valid
email address
like this
we need to check the password so we'll
say if
password
dot trim
equals
uh empty string
actually for password we don't add the
trim we can have white spaces as part of
the password that's fine and we'll say
errors
dot
password equals
um
password
must not
be empty
and if the password is not empty we need
to make sure that the password is the
same as the confirm password so here
we'll say else or say else if
password
does not equal
confirm password
so we'll say
errors dot confirm password equals
passwords um must match
if you've seen any of my tutorials
before for validation this is a pattern
that i always use
so here i'll say
return
and we're gonna return the errors and a
value for valid and this will be object
so this valid if it's true that means
there's no errors so we'll say object
dot keys
and we pass the errors
dot length so if the length of
object.keys of errors is smaller than
one that means there is no errors inside
of this so the for the data is valid so
let's save this
let's go to our users and bring this in
so here we'll say const validate
what is it
register
input
and this is const
equals require and go back two levels to
util slash validators and actually we
need this structuring because it's not
the default export
and here
under here we'll say const and we'll get
the valid
and errors
from so equals validate uh register
input and we want to pass all these
fields so here we'll pass them like this
and we get that data so we remove the
to-do's because this is done now and
here we'll say if
not
valid
then we want to return these errors that
means we have some errors so we'll say
throw new
user input error and we'll just say
errors here this doesn't matter but we
want to pass a payload with the object
errors so with the name errors and with
the value of those
errors
so here we'll save
let's check our app and here we send
empty fields and we'll check
it says validate register input is not a
function
i just mis misspelled this register
let's try again
all right we get errors and we get that
the username is not um must not be empty
and the password must not be empty so if
we put some stuff in the username
we'll get the password must not be empty
and if we put passwords that don't match
we get that they don't match and if we
put an email that's not valid we get
that
email must be valid if we revert that
change and we put
past passwords that match oops
we actually go through cool and we get
our user nice
let's actually quickly implement the
login
uh functionality
actually for this i'm going to create a
validator for login data as well so
we'll say module dot
exports exports
dot validate
login
input
and this will take only two things so
username and password
and then it will have
the same as the other one an empty
errors object and we'll say we can just
copy this
and paste it twice so if username
then username must not be empty and then
if password
and password must not be empty
this needs to be capital p
and here we'll do the same we return
errors and
and that and now prettier will format it
and let's copy that let's go to our
users here we
want to import it as well so here we'll
say
put it next to that and of course before
we create our mutation we need to add it
to our type definitions so here we'll
say
login we'll take we don't need the type
because it only takes two things so
we'll take a username
of type string and required and a
password
of type string and it's required as well
and you return a user and that's
required let's save let's go back
here you know mutation we'll say async
login
oops
login it will take
so it will take the parent we don't need
that so we'll do that underscore and
here we'll destructure username and
password
and remember because we have them
straight away as arguments in the type
defs where is it here we don't need to
actually just destruct from a type
all right so here we'll say
const
errors
and valid equals
validate login input and we pass the
username
and the password
actually let's uh let's put a comma here
so that squiggly line goes away
and here we'll say
we need to get this user from the
database
because if it doesn't exist we need to
return an error because we can't log in
a new user that doesn't exist so here
we'll say const user equals
await
user dot find
one
and the condition will be the username
must equal the username so just by
username like that
and here it will say if not user so if
this user doesn't exist we need to throw
an error but this will be a different
error this is not an error for the for
the fields themselves this is a another
error so i'm going to give it its own
name so we'll say errors dot general
equals
user
not
found
and here i'll say throw new oops
throw new
what is it user input error
and i'll just say wrong
wrong threads or credentials
oops
initials
and pass an object with the object
errors in it
else
we want to compare this password to the
actual password of the user to make sure
that the password is correct so we'll
say const
match
and we'll be we'll say
await
be crypt we'll use bcrypt again to
compare them bcrib dot compare
and we're going to compare the password
to the password of the user so to user
dot password
and
here it will say if not match if they
don't match
then we want to return an error again so
we'll do
actually here it's not wrong credentials
here it's user not found
user not found
we'll copy the same stuff
here we'll say here it's actually here
that's wrong credentials so wrong
credentials
like that
and if we get here that means the user
has successfully logged in i mean the
password is correct so let's actually
issue a token for them so we'll say
const token and uh
we need to use the same function from
here so let's actually make this into
its own function
let's copy this code
and i'm going to create a function here
a helper function will say
constor function
generate
token
and you will take a user
and you will return
the
this jws dot sign and you will replace
res with user
and it will return us a token with the
with this data so here let's copy this
so here we'll say token equals
generate token from res
and let's copy this
let's go up here
do the same here but here we called it
user so it will generate token from user
and it will return the same data that we
returned here so we can just copy this
and go up here
we will return the token except here the
user is called user and not response or
result all right let's save this
and
let's see if our validation is working
and our
red login
resolver is working so here we'll say
mutation login
and this will take a username
which is going to be user
and the password which is going to be
actually let's leave them empty to test
out the validation
and here let's uh let's get all fields
so email
token
uh username
and created at
send
okay
oh because we we have actually a user
that's got um that's got a username and
a password of empty strings
plus i forgot to throw an error if
if the valid is false from the
validation not even using that value so
here before we find the user we want to
say if
not valid
then here we want to
throw the same type of error
and here we'll say
we'll just say errors
and pass this errors here let's save
and if i go back here i should get some
errors
okay the development server didn't start
okay it started now
send the same query and there we go you
get errors user name must not be empty
and if i put user here that goes away
but we still get password must not be
empty and we do one two three four
to seven that's the wrong password we'll
say wrong credentials and if i put the
correct password it should log us in
and it does cool all right so we're done
with authentication this has been a long
one but we've done quite a lot now we've
refactored our app our dx developer
experience is going to be much much
better
our application is coming together now
in the last video we were able to
implement the register and login
mutations to register users and log them
in and give them authentication tokens
that they will use to now post and
delete
posts from our database which we haven't
implemented yet but we will in this
video
will also implement a query for fetching
a single post for the single post page
in our front end later but before we do
any of that i wanted to address this
comment
by
sherman no rot i hope i didn't butcher
the pronunciation of your name he's got
the picture of the shaman from
hearthstone which is pretty cool all
right so
he says would be nice to show what the
say hi function returns in the front end
i know it's useless but it shows us how
all wires connect uh it's not useless
it's actually pretty important to try to
understand things on a lower level and
what's actually happening behind the
scenes
uh i will not demonstrate the say hi
because that's too basic i will
demonstrate the login mutation and guys
don't confuse yourself at the end of the
day what graphql is is just we're still
sending an http request a post request
with somebody the only difference is now
that graphql
processes this body and re replies um
responds in a different manner than
traditional rest so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to demonstrate that on
postman so i'll copy this localhost 5000
paste that here
and i'll copy this body
and let me make sure to change the post
to
the request to the post request and the
body to raw
application json
and here i will have a body
an object and you will have a key query
and by the way this needs to always be
query even if it's a mutation this key
has to be called query and here we'll
have a string and inside of that we'll
put our mutation but this is not a
multi-line string so this needs to be on
one line let's
put this back on one line like this
like this and i got my server running so
that should be fine
all right so the only difference we need
to escape these quotation marks
otherwise they just
end our string so we put the back
um slash on them and here we just send
our request
and there we go we get a 200 response
and we get our token and all the data
that we got on the graphql playground
the exact same thing guys it's just at
the end of the day it's just a post
request with a query body with your
mutation or query inside it you can as
well have another field for variables
here and you can put those variables
there and that's less confusing but
we're not going to use this method
because even on the client we're not
going to send the requests like this and
actually you can do this from the client
using any http library like axios or
anything but we will use apollo client
which makes it even easier to interact
with our graphql server all right so
that's that let's actually jump into the
code of our application and implement
some more functionality all right let's
go to our type definitions and create
three more um queries and mutations here
we'll have a query called get post and
this will take a post id
of type id and that's required and in
return it will return a post so this
will get only one post
and here we will add two more mutations
and this will be the create post
mutation
uh to create a post and this will take
only a body of type string and that's
required and it will return a post and
that's required
and here we'll have the delete post
it will take a post id of type id and
that's required and it will return just
a string it doesn't matter what it
returns as long as it deletes it
successfully all right let's save that
and let's go to posts resolvers and here
we'll add the other resolver for get
post so here we'll say async get post
and we'll get the parent and we will get
from the argument we'll destructure this
um post id
and here we'll say try
and here we'll say const post
equals
await
post the model dot
find by id and we'll pass it the post id
and here we need to say if post because
we could give it like a wrong id or some
or an id of a post that's been deleted
and that could be null so we'll say if
post so if it exists we just returns it
return it so return post
else we need to
throw
new
error
and say post not found
and here
if the try catch
if the uh there was any error we'll say
catch error and we'll say throw oops
throw
[Music]
new
error
with the error object all right let's
test that out so the server is already
running it's restarting for me i'm going
to refresh here just to make sure i get
all the new queries so here instead of
saying get posts and by the way um the
playground inference the query if you
omit this if you don't say query it will
think that this is a query so we'll say
get post and we'll pass it the post id
of this one post that we have in our
database so pass it here and we will get
the id body created at
and the username
all right let's hit that and we get that
post and if i give it a wrong id
we get post not found and we get this
error all right cool so that's working
let's work on the create post
um
resolver so we go to users
and here in mutation
we go
down here is that
yeah that's the register
so here we'll say
async
create post or actually let's put this
in the um in the posts um resolvers it
doesn't make a difference but since this
has a lot of code already i'll put it
here so yeah so that's not there
we go here and we say underneath this
query we'll say mutation
and we'll say
async create post
and this will take the parent
and it will take so
we will destructure the body
and inside of here what we need to do is
um the way our protected resolver is
going to work is that our user will log
in and get an authentication token and
then they need to put it in an
authorization header and send that
header with the request and we need to
get that token and then decode it and
get information from it make sure that
the user is authenticated and then
create a post we don't want anyone
creating a post and i see a lot of
people making the mistake and adding
this authentication middleware as a
middleware for express itself that means
that we'll run each on each request even
on non-protected routes the way we're
going to do it here we're going to have
the third argument in the apollo server
which is the context here we'll say
context
and this will take a call back and here
we get
anything that's passed from from before
this poll server and we get the request
and the response from express so we need
to say uh request actually we get we get
them in an object so here we'll say
request we destructure the request and
we just want to forward that request so
what this will do it will take that
request body and we'll forward it to the
context and now we can access the
request body in our context so if we go
back to posts
now if we use this third argument
context inside this context we will have
the request body so we can access the
headers and determine that this user is
authenticated and we can do all of that
inside of here but since we will use
this
middleware or helper function in
multiple routes so we need to put it in
its own function so here in the util i'm
going to create a new file call it check
auth like this
and here we will need a json web token
to decode the token that we got so we'll
say jwt equals require
json web token
and here we'll say
module dot exports
equals this function that will take the
context and do the following and we also
need the secret that we have because we
will use that as well to
verify the tokens because we used it to
encode the tokens so here we'll say
const and this structure the secret
key uh and this will be equal require
and from the same level actually not
from the sale level it's back one level
config
all right so here we need to get this
header so we will say const
auth
header
equals because at the end of the day
this context will have a
context will have an object and amongst
many things it will have headers inside
of it and inside the headers we need to
get to this authorization header and
here we'll say the auth header equals
context
dot
actually.request
dot headers
dot authorization
so here we need to check for it because
maybe someone didn't send this header so
we'll say if auth header
now if we have it then we need to get
the token from it and a convention when
working with authorization tokens
that we send this header with a value of
bearer space and then we put the token
here so what we need to say here we need
to get that token itself and we say cons
token equals
auth header dot split
and we split this by uh
bearer
space meaning it will have two strings
the first one is bearer space and the
second is the actual token so we need to
get the second so we need to get index
one
because a split returns an array of
couple of strings so here we'll say if
token because this can as well still not
exist so we'll say if token
now we need to verify the token and make
sure that this we issued this token and
is still valid and not expired so we'll
say try
and because this could fail and we'll
say const user equals
jwt dot yeah verify
and we pass it the token and we pass it
our secret key
and now we'll say return user so this if
this fails it will go to the catch block
and we'll say
catch error
and here we can we can throw any type of
error but let's be more specific and
let's uh import this type of error we'll
say const and we need to import
authentication
error
from not from equals require
require
apollo
server like this
and now if we fail in verifying that we
want to throw that so we throw
throw
new
authentication error
and we will say
invalid
slash expired
token
because if this fails it will come here
that means it's either invalid or
expired or blacklisted as well but we're
not doing that in our application now
after these if statements we need to
throw some errors as well because if
this if statements failed um
if these if uh conditions failed um that
means we don't we either don't have a
token or we don't have an auth header so
we need to as well tell the user that
why this failed so we'll say here throw
new
error
and this will say
authentication
token
must be
well actually not provided here was
provided but maybe it was the wrong
format so we'll say must be
and we escape a
thing quotation mark and we'll say
like this bearer space and token
formatted like that and then we will
close this
and here we need to throw another error
if we that means if we didn't get an
auth header we'll say let's just copy
this
and we'll say uh authentication token
must be we'll say provided
provided
or actually authentication header
because here if we get here that means
we didn't have the header itself
all right let's save all of this and
let's go to posts and actually get this
check auth function so we'll say const
check
auth equals require oops
require and we go back
what is it two levels
yeah two levels into util slash check
dash auth like this
now here we will use the context to get
the user so we'll say const user equals
check auth and we pass it the context
now because the way we structured it
here that if we don't have a headache
throws an error here if the the token is
not valid it throws an error here so if
there's anything wrong with the token an
error will be thrown here otherwise we
will get a user and this will return a
user which means if we get to this block
of code right here after this that means
there was no errors that means there is
a user definitely here that means we can
proceed with this action and allow it
and actually create this post so we'll
say const new post equals new post we
have yeah we have the model we have the
model here so we'll say new post
and we'll pass it the body
like that because we already destructed
it from here and we need to pass it the
user remember in our post model uh where
is it right here
uh right here the post we gave it this
user we can still attach that id and it
will auto populate it if we want to get
the user from the post later so we'll
say user is user
dot id
oops id i don't know why it's auto
correcting me
and here we'll say username
is user.username
like that
and we need to give a created add which
is new date
to
iso string like that
now we need to save this post so we'll
say const post equals
new post
dot save
and actually i forgot to put a wait
because this is asynchronous
and here we need to just return this
post to return post all right let's see
if all of this works and we're checking
the uh the thing let's do here a console
log just to make sure that we have our
user so we console.log user
and let's test this out all right so we
go here
and
let's open a new tab and here i'll say
mutation
create post i want to pass it a body and
this body will say
this is another
post
and let's get from it all the fields
so create that and the username all
right this should fail and tell us that
we need an authentication token
but it doesn't it says cannot return oh
because we didn't add this mutation so
here in the index
uh we want to say as well that we want
the mutations from post resolvers oops
what is the what is that
resolvers.mutation
all right let's save make sure that it
started it has
let's go here let's send that
cool it says
authentication header must be provided
that's actually a wrong authorization
header let me change that
so
authentication token that's fine but
here it's an authorization header
although which is actually a misnomer
it should be authentication but whatever
so if we send okay let's send again it's
still restarting the server cool
authorization header must be provided so
let's provide one so if we just
uh slide this up like extend this
we can here add some http headers so
here we say authorization
and here let's put an empty string and
see what happens
okay
i see even an empty string is counted as
that it's it's not truthy so let's put
something some gibberish and then now it
says that it must be bearer space token
all right let's put bearer space and
then some gibberish that's not actually
a valid token it will say invalid slash
expired token now let's actually put in
a real token so here let's log in again
let's copy this token
go to create post and here bearer space
and we paste that and now let's run it
and there we go we get this and the post
was created and the username was
assigned that user that we logged in
with
and if we go to get post here let's
change this into get posts and get all
of them
okay let me remove that actually
and there we go we get this um another
post has been sent and it's added to our
database
there's one little problem here is that
the latest post is big is coming
last in the array but we don't want that
we want the latest posts to be first and
on the array to show them on our website
so we can just sort the result from get
posts so let's go to the post resolvers
and here in gut posts we just need to
chain another method here called uh
sort
and the sort will take a condition and
we will sort by created at and to tell
mongoose that we want to in descending
order we just say -1
let's save make sure that it's restarted
i think it's restarted mode nodemon is
behaving a bit weird lately
all right there we go so another another
post now it's first instead of being
last all right let's now implement the
delete post let's go here let's go down
here in mutation we add another one
we'll say async delete post
and this will take um
the parent and it will take the
structure the post id from the arguments
and of course we need the context as
well
and here we'll do the same we'll say
const user equals check auth and we pass
it the context and now even if we have
the user this isn't enough because we
need to make sure that this user is the
creator of the post they want to delete
we don't want any user to delete any
post they're only allowed to delete
their own posts so here we'll simply say
if
user dot username
equals
the post dot
actually we need to get the post first
and we need to wrap everything in a try
block so we'll say try
const post we need to find that post
first
is a weight
equals
a weight
post dot
find by id post id
and then here we put the if statement
and we'll say if user the username is
the same as post.username that means
this is the owner of the post so we just
await post dot
delete ops delete i hate the word delete
here we just after it's deleted we just
return the string post deleted
successfully
and then here else if it's not that
means
we're like yo this is not your post you
can't delete it
so we say throw new
did we bring that i want to bring
authentication error here as well so
it's got to check also get the same one
from a pulse server copy it and
actually this is from the library so
i'll put it up there and we'll say throw
new authentication error and this will
say action
not allowed
and we need to handle as well if this
try block fails so we'll say catch
error
and we'll say throw
oops throw
new
error
error like that all right let's save
let's look at our post so we have two
posts
by user i actually added the two new
users let's try to log in with a
different user so i'll log in with jane
and she has the same password because
why not
and let's go here
and we can actually have multiple
mutations so i'll call this create post
i mean multiple operations on the same
tab so here i'll have the other mutation
and you can name it whatever you want
i'll name this as well the same delete
post and this will be the mutation
delete post and it will take a post id
and we'll give it the post id of
where is it this one that was created by
user so we'll try to delete that but the
thing is let's try to delete it with the
token of jane so this shouldn't be
allowed okay so here
i will paste that token from jane and
hit
play and hit the delete post and it says
authentication or error action not
allowed cool so j can't delete users
post but if i go here and press ctrl z
it will go back to the token from user
and uh or actually let's get a new token
because why not so here we'll say user
and we'll get that token from user
and then go here
and bearer and paste that token and
press play delete post there we go post
deleted successfully and if we fetch all
posts again we find that that post has
actually been deleted
hello class
nice to see you again
i have missed you have you missed me
well actually no wait wait a second
maybe you've been doing like the classes
in a row and you've done you've just
finished class three and you're now here
and you're like wait a second i'm just
listening to your voice like five
minutes ago anyway for me it's been like
24 hours ago since i recorded the last
video so i definitely have missed you
all right enough of that let's actually
crack into this video where we will
implement
holy implement yes comments and likes
all right we'll implement ways of
submitting comments and likes to our
posts because right now actually if we
look at our database right here this is
the only post i have
and if you look there is a comment and
likes array but they're empty but and we
can't fetch them with graphql we can't
edit them so let's actually fix that
okay let's go to vs code or whatever
editor you're using i'm going to go to
the type definitions and i'm going to
close this terminal
and keep the server running here in post
i'm going to add the arrays for likes
and comments so here i'm going to say
comments
and this will be an array so we do
square brackets and we say
this is a different type that we'll
create
and here we'll put the exclamation mark
and you can as well put an exclamation
mark inside which means this array has
to contain at least one element we
rarely ever do that there are some use
cases but we're not going to do that now
we're only going to require that we
return an array even if it's an empty
array that's fine all right let's say
likes as well here will return an array
of likes so like and then it's required
so let's create these types so here we
have the oops didn't mean to do that all
right here we say type comment
and uh well let's look at our post
so yeah this will have a um
a body a created ad and a username so
here we'll of course we will have an id
as well so we'll do id and that's
required enough type id we'll have a
created add
and that's a string and it's required
we'll have a username
a required string and the body of the
comment and that's as well a required
string let's do the uh
type like
this will hold an id
and a created ad
which is a string
and what else yeah username of who
actually liked this
so this will be a string
all right so here we're going to add our
mutations to create and delete a comment
and to like a post so here we'll say
create
comment
and this will take two things the post
id
so which post do you want to comment on
or does the user want to comment on
actually that's a lowercase d
and this is a string and that's required
and the body of the comment so body and
that's a string as well and we will
return that post that's been
commented on
and here we'll say delete comment as
well to delete a comment
and
does this take yeah it will take a post
id so post id
um
id
and comment id
you can take just the comment id but uh
taking the post id
provides us the ability to check whether
that post is still up or not
uh here we'll say post because usually
you might have a mechanism where if a
post is deleted you delete all the
comments and then if you look for a
comment that doesn't exist anymore it
might cause a problem all right here
we'll add another one which is like post
so it will take the id
and that's it just the id of the post
oops id and that's required
and it will return that post and notice
we don't have a
an unlike mutation because this like
post will work as a toggle so if we've
liked that post we will unlike it and if
we haven't liked it we will uh like it
from zero from i mean from scratch
whatever i don't know what i was going
with that all right let's go to posts
so
here at the bottom we'll add this uh
these mutations
or actually
post is getting a bit massive we have no
obligation to put them in
like in a specific file we can even
create as many files as we want i'll
create another one actually for comments
here i'll say comments.js
and here i'll say
what do we need we need the post
model so here we will say require and we
go back to levels and we go to models
slash post
and here we'll
say module dot exports
and here we'll have a mutation key
and before i forget uh let's add that to
our index so here we'll say we'll import
that file i'll just copy this and paste
it and replace users with comments
and here we'll add that mutation field
from the comments resolvers
so we'll say comments
resolvers dot mutation like this
all right let's go back here we have the
create comment so we'll say async
create
create
and by the way guys you can have it as
error functions it doesn't make a
difference i'll use that syntax for now
just to show you that you can do that as
well so we'll say create comment and
that will be an async function and you
will take the parent so actually we
don't need it so we can just say uh like
this just an underscore and we will
destructure from the arguments the two
things the post id and the body and of
course we'll need the context to make
sure that our user has
actually logged in so here we'll do that
arrow and here we need to get our user
so we'll say const user equals
check
auth
and he will pass it the context
and
of course when we get here if you know
by now that that means we're logged in
so we'll do some basic validation and
we'll say if body
dot trim
equals an empty string that means
someone tried to submit an empty um
comment so we'll throw an error so we'll
say throw
not just any error we'll get the user
input error so here we'll say
const
user input
error
equals require
apollo
server like this
all right so here we'll throw that error
through new
user input error and it will say
empty comment and i'll attach a payload
of errors to it with just one error i'm
not actually sure i'm gonna use these in
the on the client but i'm gonna send
this payload anyway
uh here we'll say comment
body must
must not
be empty almost said must be empty which
is ridiculous
so here after the if statement so if
it's not empty then let's get this post
so we'll say const post equals
post dot
find by id and we pass it the post id
and here we'll say if post oops
if post
so because it could be null actually i
forgot to add a weight here this is a
weight because it's asynchronous
and here we'll say if post then we want
to say post because mongoose turns our
um data models into like just json
objects and i mean just like normal
javascript objects so i can just access
the comments array like this
post.comments which is pretty cool and
here we'll add it to it but we want to
add it to the top because it's the
newest one so use the unshift method and
say unshift and we want to add
a body of body so we can just say that
a username
of user
actually we're gonna need just the
username from user so we can destructure
that and say username like this and here
we can just say username
cool all right here we'll say created at
and this will be a new date
to
iso
string like this
all right now we need to save the post
so here we'll say
await post dot save
and we need to return it so we'll return
this post
so else if the post doesn't exist then
we throw
uh what is this this is gonna be um
is this gonna be an a user input error
yeah it is a user input error
because
yeah because they try to access um an id
that doesn't exist and usually our
client shouldn't expose an id that
doesn't exist
and we say
post not found and uh yeah that's it for
the create comment
all right let's save that let's save the
index make sure our server has restarted
successfully because nodemon has been a
bit weird i don't know why it's getting
stuck on this restarting all right i had
to restart node 1 i don't know why it's
doing that all right let's refresh here
and let's log in to get a new token
because the other token is probably
expired it's been 24 hours
so here we'll go to
so here we'll get posts to make sure
that we have this post actually we can
do a
multiple operations here so they will
call this um we'll just call this posts
and here we'll do our create comment
mutation here we'll say mutation uh
comment it doesn't matter what you name
it here you just need to say here create
comment not post comment
and this takes a post id
and before because i have the token on
the clipboard i want to put the token
first here so i'll say authorization
as
bearer
space and paste that token and here i'm
going to copy this id and paste it here
and i'll do body
and by the way this uh this comma is not
necessary you can omit it or you can
leave it depends on your preference and
the body will be
new comment
on
only post i don't know
and we will get a post back so we can
just get the id
the body and let's actually get the
comments because now we can have that
array the id the created ad the username
and the body
let's uh hit control enter
check auth is not defined oh yeah i
didn't import it so here we want to say
here const
check
auth
equals require
and we want to go back two levels to
util slash check auth
all right let's save
come on node one you can do it
yes
thank you
all right here we can um say comment
there we go we get our data and we get
the comment and now if we even fetch
posts
actually we need to add comments
i mean it's got it just to make sure
with the other
um
with the other query so we fetch the
post there we go our post has a comment
and we can even submit another one and
uh
say
another one
and say comment and there we go we got
our post with two comments sweet let's
now um create the delete comment
uh
what is it resolver yeah resolver
here we'll say
async i'm gonna close the terminal
uh delete
com
i hate delete comment
and of course this will take the parent
and
the post id
and comment
id
and we'll take the context
and here we'll say const
username will this
destructure the username
check auth
and we pass it the context
get the user from the token
find the post oops
const post equals await
post to the model
dot find by id and we pass it the post
id
and we need to say if post
say
uh here what we need to do is
what do we do oh yeah okay we get the
index of um so we find that comment we
find the index of that comment in the
array of comments and then we delete
that at that index
and here we'll say const
what is a comma let's call it comment
index
in index equals post dot comments
dot find index
and of comment i'll say c where comment
dot id
equals
this comment id that we passed
to our
to our function and here we'll say so
because we need to check because maybe
some other user is trying to delete some
other user's comments so we will say if
post dot comments
add that index so comment
index
index like this dot
username
equals
username that we got from this token
that means this is the owner of the
comment so we can delete it so we'll say
post
dot comments
dot
remove oh i mean
splice there is no such thing as remove
i just made that up so splice comment we
start at the comment index and we remove
just one
and here of course we need to save we'll
say await post dot save
and did i say oh wait here yeah i did
okay
we'll se and then we'll return that post
else if it's not to the owner of the
post this is a different
person we'll throw
throw
new
authentication
authentication we haven't imported that
error
and we'll say action not
allowed and you notice sometimes we're
throwing an error without throwing a um
without sending a payload with errors
because we don't need to show this on
the client because there will never be a
delete button for a user that doesn't
own that uh that comment this is just a
safety check instead of safety net
instead of like in case a user actually
tries to delete a comment that that's
not theirs using some sort of like code
all right so here so this is if the post
exists so we need to chain an else on
this if it doesn't exist we want to
throw
a new user input error and we'll say
post not
found
sweet let's test this
actually uh we need to import this
authentication error
here actually it needs to be
in alphabetical order let's save
all right cool nodemon was nice this
time all right so let's actually create
a new window i'm just going to copy
these headers from here create a new tab
and paste the same headers here
and here we'll say
delete actually mutation
delete
comment
and the post id
will be
let's uh this well we all we have only
one post here so post id is this and i
can put this on a different line and say
comment id is
let's delete the first comment so we
leave the another one so we'll take this
id and then we put the id here and we
get the post back so we can say id of
the post and then let's just get
comments and id and username and body
all right let's send this
oh it get it gets the post back
yeah okay it's working
all right
so we get the post back when we delete
the comment and if we try to delete the
other comments so let's take this id and
we put it here and we send it and there
we go our comments are empty so we
removed all the comments that we just
posted all right let's now create a way
to um
get the likes and actually add a like to
um to our
posts so here in
i'm gonna add it to the posts
here at the bottom
i'll say async like
post
and this will take
so the usual parent which is going to be
just an underscore
uh post id
and the context
it's getting a bit repetitive but
sometimes it happens like this with crud
that you have to write the same code for
different resources so here we'll say
check auth and we pass context
and we need to find the post so we'll
say const
post equals weight
post dot find by id and we pass it the
post id like this
and of course we need to say if post
and here we'll say
uh what we need to do is we need to find
this like we need to make sure that it
exists so we'll say if
because we could later delete it you
know so what we need to do we'll say if
post dot likes
dot find
a like where the like dot id
equals
or is it actually no the like username
because we don't have access to the id
we have access to the username because
a
user can have only one like on a post so
if they have this like already we just
delete it so we'll say
like this because username so this is
this returns a um an object right and if
it doesn't find it it will return
undefined so it will be not truthy so
we'll say if and if this returns if it's
true if the returns alike that means
we've already liked let's put a comment
here we'll say post already liked
unlike
it
and here else that means we don't have a
like so it's not liked we'll say not
liked
uh like
post
so here we want to unlike it we want to
remove that like so we'll say post
likes like this equals post dot likes
dot filter
[Music]
like where
like dot username
equal uh does not equal
the username so we leave at all of them
uh all the ones that don't have the same
username as our user so we just remove
that one with this username
all right and here we need to say await
post dot save
and then here we need to add a like so
here we'll say post
dot likes
dot push it doesn't matter if you add it
to the end or to the beginning because
uh
we're not gonna show likes based on
created that just going to show a number
of them so we'll say the username is
username and it needs a created ad
and that's new
date
dot 2 iso
string
and yeah that's it just the username and
the date and here we'll say await post
or actually no
uh this await post because we're editing
the post no matter what so this await
post can be after this if statement so
after we're done we either we remove the
like or we added the like now here we
will say await post dot save
and we'll say return
post like this
and this is an if else if the post
doesn't exist we will say we're not in a
block we'll just say like this throw new
user input what is this
user
input
error
and this will say post
not found oh because it's not imported
that's why it
it's finished with that
user input error
sweet i think we're done here
so this works for both liking and
disliking or unlike and rather so and we
are returning the likes because we added
that to our
type so let's actually test this
so let's go here and instead of delete
comment we will have a different
mutation here we'll say like post
did our server restart
yes
thank you nodemon i feel like i should
be grateful each time all right here is
a post id and it will be this id right
here
and we'll pass it like this
and we want to get the id
or just the body and username
username
i want to get the likes array and from
the likes i'm going to get the id and
the username so let's submit this cool
so we get a like and if we look here
just to make sure we fetch posts
actually let's add likes here likes
and we get the id they create that
or just like id and username cool so you
get a like and here if i press again
that like is gone and if i press it's
back i pressed it's gone cool we just uh
did the two functionalities in one
route or one operation one mutation
whatever
all right so
this is it for this video
or actually no let me add
because there's some
cool thing i want to show you and i
don't want to make a video just for that
i want to show you how to do a
subscription now we're not going to
implement it in our front end you can if
you want but i'm just going to show you
how subscriptions work because they're
pretty cool so i'll say type
subscription
generally people don't use them when
like getting new posts or new uh
comments and stuff like this because if
your app is massive it will be too much
traffic and too much bandwidth people
use them for polling and for chat apps
and whatever i might do like if you want
me to do some sort of like pulling up or
like chat up let me know in the comments
all right here i'll add a subscription
and let's call this new post
i want the subscription to each time
when a new post is created to like um
show whoever is subscribed to this that
look this is the new post that's been
subscribe
created
all right so in our index we're gonna
need something else from apollo server
called pub
sub
which means publish subscribe or publish
a subscribe it's a pattern anyway here
we'll say const pub sub
not like this pub sub like this we'll
say new
instantiate a
an instance of this and we just pass it
to our context
so we can use it in uh in our resolvers
let's save this
where do we go let's go to
posts yeah posts
here um
here i want to add so we got to this
mutation it ends like here
and here we'll say subscription
and here we'll have our subscription new
post
and this will have an object inside of
there will have a subscribe
uh like this oops what is that subscribe
and the inside of here will return or
actually let's do it as an arrow
function because it will be like shorter
the syntax will be shorter so here we'll
do like this and it will take the parent
and our we have no arguments so we can
omit this as well so we can do two
underscores
and here we need to get the um pub sub
pub
sub like this
here we'll say
we'll return pub sub
dot async iterator iterator
and here let's call this uh
i'll just call it a new post new
post
uh it's the convention to have like all
caps like this as a
it's a an event type and
it's like a type of kind of received
type thing i don't know
it's just a convention all right so here
we want to as well publish because this
is the subscription we want as well the
publication from where we create a post
so right here after the post has been
created and saved we're gonna say we
have access to our context which holds
the pub sub and we'll say context
dot pub
sub
dot what is it publish yes publish
publish and we publish
a name a trigger name of
the same name that we had earlier so new
underscore post
and the payload will have new post
with the value of that post that's been
created this one right here
all right let's save
okay we'll save subscription
and our subscription is new post and
we'll get
the id the body
the creator that
username
comments everything everything
we just get the created out of the
comments and likes because we don't have
even comments right now on likes
okay subscription field must return
async iterable
received undefined
ready
where are we
returns async iterate oh okay my bad
here we need to actually add a field
subscription subscription
and here we want to spread the did i put
it in post here i put it in post posts
resolvers
sorry guys it's the end of the day and
i'm a bit tired so these mistakes happen
all right let's make sure all right
there's something wrong i've crashed
post resolver oh it's resolvers
save
come on
oh no demand is
being a bit annoying
so i had to restart
okay there's another problem throw new
there's something learning defining
resolvers feeling not in schema
oh
this is not mutation this is
subscription
subscription like this all right
another mistake
all right so npm start
cool server is running this time it
should work we start it and there we go
it starts to listen i want the animation
to happen so i'm just going to do it on
a new tab
so do like this there we go so we get
this cool animation of the spin and
let's try to now create another post so
he will say
[Music]
a post
for subscribers
by the way subscribe if you haven't
subscribed yet to the channel nice segue
alright so let's send this create post
damn it invalid token let's get a valid
token
let's go here
let's add this
all right let's send create post and if
we go here we see that we got a post
here and if we create another one number
two we send it create post there we go
we received another post you see like
we're like now listening using
websockets in the background and
actively listening to the new post event
and each time it publishes a new post we
actually get it we can listen on the
client and we will get this these posts
in real time as they've been posted all
right i want to show you one more thing
that is kind of useful a lot of the
times this time it's not that useful but
it's a cool trick that you can do all
right so here
i could add it here actually no i can't
add it here i'm going to add it here
what i want to do is
on the client later we're going to need
a number for the number of likes and
number of comments and we can calculate
that on our client by just saying the
array of comments dot length but we can
as well calculate that on the server and
send it to the client to minimize the
amount of computation that's happening
on the client so here we can add two
fields say like count
like count
and that's a
number
it's required and we have comment
count
as i make a mistake actually no in a
graphql it's not a number it's an int so
here it's an int as well and it's
required as well and we can get these uh
we can actually compute these and send
them
not through the mutation itself but we
can have like um
i think they're called modifiers i'm not
sure what they're called
i call them modifiers so here we can say
if we have a name of the type so if we
say post
and then we do stuff here to change any
of the fields each time any mutation or
query of subscription that returns a
post it will go through this post
modifier and apply these modifications
which is pretty cool so we can do all
sorts of um you know scenarios here so
here we will have that field name we'll
say like count
and we will say that it's an arrow
function and it will take the
parent we'll need the parent here
actually we'll need just the parent
because the parent holds the data that
comes from
the previous step actually let me show
you i'll put it as a normal function so
like count like this
and um oh it takes parent
i'm going to console log the parent just
to show you clg
parent
and here what we want to do we want to
say return we want to return a value for
this like count so what we will return
parent will hold that data for the post
and it will hold the likes in it so
we'll say return parent.likes.length
and we will do the same for comment
count
and for comment count i'm just gonna
return the value and not console.log
anything because we'll see it from the
likes one so i'll say parent and here
we'll say
no return just parent dot
comments
comments dot
length like this
all right let's save this make sure our
server starts okay it doesn't
oh yeah no no column um no semicolon
needed there
okay let me start it again okay let's
maximize our
terminal and let's go here well what
happened here
let's
what what happened to my tabs
that's strange and the font size is tiny
all right that was definitely not
planned so let me put back the font size
to 24.
and let's go here we'll put
the query get posts
and here i'll get id
body and we'll get the like count
and the comment
count
all right we'll send and there we go we
get 0 0 because these don't have any
comments on them or actually you know
what let's create them so let's say
mutation
create post
and here we'll have a body
actually no not create post
create
comment
and we'll have a
post id
of this post right here
and we will have a body
that will say
comment
and we'll just get the id back and
we need to actually log in so you say
mutation
login
username
is user
and password is one through six
and get just the token we send this we
get the token
we go here we add
an authorization
header with the value bearer
space our token
and we send our thing and we get that
and we send our query here we get that
the co we have one comment and the
comment count is one cool so it's
actually calculating them and if we look
this is the value of what parent returns
it's actually the post that's been sent
so here that's the post these are all
the posts so that's the first post and
it's got that so this is what the parent
is is the data that comes from
get posts and if you send any type of
query or mutation that returns a post it
will have to go through this modifier
and add these properties all right let's
set this to be a
an arrow function to just make it
smaller
right here we'll do like this remove
that remove this
remove the return and just do that
okay that's fine all right so we are
done with the back end i think i think
if there's any modification i'll let you
know i think yeah this is it for the
back end yeah so we're done for the
server code
i want to tell you that i made one
little change in the post
resolvers right here in the create post
i just added this if statement right
here if the body of the post is empty it
throws an error because this is a valid
a server validation thing that i forgot
to do in the series you just add this
one if statement
all right let's open up our code base
using vs code
and
so here i want to create a folder and
put our
react app in there but we don't need to
do that because we're going to use the
create react app to tool and it's going
to do that for us so here we'll say npx
create
react
app i'll call this folder client because
that's the the client application and
the rest of the code on this folder is
the server application all right so i'll
let that install and i'll be back once
it's done
all right now that it's done installing
let's open up this client folder
and uh
here i'll clean a couple of things so
we'll not be using this logo so i'll
delete it
we will not be using this index css so
i'll delete that
i'll delete everything like remove
everything in the app css because we're
going to be using semantic ui
i'll delete this app test file
and
actually in the public i'm gonna change
the title of the app
i decided to call this hi world because
it's a social media app so i'll call
this um hi
hi world like this
and save that
let's go back to the source folder and
here in the app i'm going to delete
everything inside of here i'll just have
a div for now and i'll have a header one
says hi
on hi world like this
of course we'll remove the import to
logo because that doesn't exist anymore
and
yeah let's save all of this and let's
see
let's start our server so here we'll say
npm start
and in a different terminal we'll go to
the um we'll cd into the client folder
and we'll say npm start so now we
started the server now we'll start the
client okay it says can't resolve index
css yes because something is important
yeah it's the index js is importing that
and we deleted it all right so the app
has started
and cool we get high world and uh
hopefully no errors probably none yes no
errors
and if we go back to our app i notice if
each time i save
both the development server of the
server and the client are restarting
because of nodemon on the server so
let's go here
and
in the package json we don't want
nodemon right now because we're not
making any changes on the server on the
server code so we'll add another
script here and say serve and here we'll
say just node index
and of course now if we run serve let's
say npm
run serve
now each time we make any changes it
will not uh re-trigger that run in
restart the server
the uh the server server not the client
server all right so
should be fine now
and here in the app what we need to do
right now we want to set up our apollo
client
our apollo provider and provide our
apollo client to our application so that
we will be able to connect to our
graphql server
we could do it in the app.js but
i would rather have it in a separate
component or
and here we'll say we'll call it apollo
provider
js and actually we need to install a
couple of dependencies to get that so
here um in a terminal window let's say
i'll actually make sure you're in the
client folder so cd client
and here in the client folder i'm going
to say npm install we're going to
install a couple of things
first is the apollo
slash react hooks did i mention we're
going to be using only hooks here
if you're not familiar with hooks i have
a series on hooks on this channel if you
want to dive deeper into that so we're
going to install apollo cache in memory
what we need let me look so we need
apollo link http
link http
and we need apollo client of course
so apollo client
all right that's it for now
let them install and let's go to the
provider
here this provider is basically going to
export a jsx element so we need uh react
so we'll say import react from
react
uh
here what we're going to export is a
apollo provider that wraps the
application the the entire app so we
need to import the app into this
provider so here we'll say import
app from the same directory slash
app like this
and we need apollo client so we say
import apollo client from
apollo dash client
here we have we import the
uh the in-memory the cache in memory
um
libraries so here we'll say import
and what is it called in memory caches
in memory
cache
from
apollo
cache
in memory
and usually you'll install a library
called apollo boost and it does all of
this for you but i've had issues with
apollo boost when it comes to
authentication tokens and saving them
and setting a middleware for checking a
token so i'm gonna do the setup myself
um here we'll say import it's just a
tiny setup just one file that you write
and you'll never touch again so here
we'll say create
http link we need um
we need this from
um
let me type this we need it from apollo
link http so here we'll say from
apollo
link
http we're importing a bunch of things
this is the last one
this is apollo provider
so this is the jsx element that will
provide the client to our app and this
is going to come from apollo at apollo
slash react hooks
all right so here we'll say const http
link
we'll just instantiate or actually we
need to call that
so we'll say create
http link
and here we'll pass it some options we
just need the uri for now and this is
going to be pointing to our graphql
server so what is the endpoint for our
server which is just local host 5000 so
we'll say http
and here we'll say local
host
5000 of course this in production this
will be different so bear in mind
here we'll create our client so say
const client equals new
apollo client
and here we'll pass
a link which is this http link that we
created
and we'll pass
a cache value that will store any um
cached
data and here we'll just instantiate the
in-memory cache so you say in new in
memory cache like this call it like that
and here we just need to export this
provider so we say export default
and we'll export
apollo
provider and this takes a client which
is going to be
the client that created right here
and this will wrap the app so we need to
put the app here
and now we need to use this in the index
js so here we'll say
import
what is the apollo
provider
provider
from
uh same directory apollo provider and
here instead of rendering the app we
just passed this apollo provider
so like this so we don't need the app
and actually we don't need any jsx
elements here so we don't need react so
we can just do that
uh let's save everything
let's make sure that our app is still
running
okay so
import error apollo provider not
exported
is it not exported
oh here it's apollo provider like that
and we need to put it here as well pull
up provider let's save all right it runs
just fine
and if we go to our app it says hi world
of course there's no difference but
uh by the way did i mention um you need
to install
apollo dev tools for chrome you can say
apollo dev tools chrome
and go here and just add it to your uh
chrome as an extension and if you're
using any other
browser maybe you'll find it maybe not i
don't know so you just add it to your
browser and here if i click f12 actually
let me refresh this
click f12
uh where is the apollo did i not add it
okay for some reason i had to close the
dev tools and open them again all right
so here in apollo we get this graphq
graphical tool the same tool that we get
on our server endpoint and here if we
say query
say get there we go we're getting our
queries right here that means our
apollo provider in our app is actually
accessing the server and if we say get
posts i want to get the id
and get the body
and click control enter and there we go
we're actually fetching the posts from
our database and uh
apollo provider is connected to our
server and everything is working fine
well hello class and welcome to class 2
on the channel clast so many classes
and we're not even using class-based
component how did that come to be
all right so enough of the nuances so
now that we've hooked up our application
with uh apollo and by hooked up our
application with apollo i mean we set up
our apollo provider and we connected our
apollo client to our apollo server
apollo apollo so before we use any um
graphql queries and mutations and fetch
any data and show it we need to set up
as um our application because we need to
set up some basic markup because this
doesn't look good alright so
uh what i want to focus on this video is
to introduce the router and create
different pages mainly we're going to
create the home and login page
page login and register page all right
i'm gonna stop talking and start writing
code
okay
so make sure you got your server running
at port 5000 and
the client running
and let's open up a new tab and here
let's install uh react router dom so
let's say npm install
and react
uh router
and dom and since we're installing stuff
i just want to quick say quickly we're
gonna be using like i said semantic ui
uh it's really cool you can actually
install it through the um command line
and kind of customize a couple of things
but i'm just gonna install it
just install the css and install this
react integration called semantic ui
react very creative
and
so what we're going to do is we're just
okay let's go to get started we're just
going to run this yarn add or npm
install semantic ui react and we need to
install the css as well so we're going
to say install semantic ui css so we're
going to add those two so here we'll say
semantic
ui css and semantic
ui
react
let those install and uh here in the app
uh js file uh let's bring the router and
route so here we'll say import
browser
router
i'm gonna give it an lds router because
it makes more sense
i'm pretty sure one day they'll change
it to just router
all right so here we'll say react from
react router dom
and uh here above our css we want to
bring semantic ui
um
just in case you don't know the reason
why because we if we want to change
anything uh we will change it through
our custom css and the fact that we have
it after it's going to override the
default styles from semantic ui aka
cascading so semantic ui css slash
semantic
dot min dot css like this
so now the css we we have it in our app
and we can use the semantic ui react and
just use those react components
um
so here actually here instead of this
div we're going to put the router so
we'll say router
and inside of here we'll have
so we'll have our routes so first route
will be the home route so we'll say
exact
path and the path will be to slash
component
component will be home
by the way i just want to say quickly
i'm not going to be explaining the kind
of the basics of react because this is
more of a apollo um course if you want
to know the basics to react you can do
my
0 to 60 tutorial or you can do anyone
else's as long as you learn the basics
all right so here's another route is the
login route so it will say exact path
equals
oh not equals actually oh yeah equals
i'm confusing myself guys all right so
register or login
and component
will be login
of course we'll create these components
in a second let's just copy this
click here and do register
this will be
capital r
so here it will create a um
oh i've already created the folder
components but i'll create another
folder called pages
and inside of here we'll have
login.js
we'll have
home.js
and we'll have a register.js
here we'll say rfc why is it not working
or rcf yeah rcf
all right so here we'll say at the
bottom export default
register
and this by the way even though they're
functions but you have to have them
pascal cased meaning the first letter
has to be capital some reason it doesn't
work if it's not
um all right so here we'll just say
we'll just have a header one for now
saying register
page
save let's copy all of this go to the
home and just ctrl d here and say home
so home page and these are rename to
home let's go to the login as well paste
this and just
say log in here just to have a couple of
different pages for now we'll populate
them later
let's close them
let's import them so here we'll say
import
we'll have home from
same directory pages
pages slash
home
and we can just copy this two more times
so here we'll say login
and here we'll say register
all right one thing that i want to do is
i want to have a navbar at the top and
we can go here in
react semantic ui.com and go to
right here menu
they call it menu and
i want to get this one oh no not this
one this one this one that looks like
tabs looks cool
let's actually just copy this entire
component just copy that
and let's go to our app
and i'm going to create a component here
call it menu
bar
they call it menu so i'm going to call
it menu why not
i'm going to close this terminal
so here um
this is a class-based component of
course we need to change that because we
only want functional components
so here we'll say function
what is it menu bar
and i'm going to export it
export default
menu bar
and here instead of component we're
going to get use state
and
right here instead of state like this
we will say
const
active
item
and set
active
item
equals use state
and this will start with an empty string
and the way these works uh work is that
each menu item you have here has a name
and if the active property is true that
means it's going to be highlighted that
means we're active on this page right
now and this name will be
rendered as the name of the tab with the
first letter capitalized so if this
returns true that means if the active
item right here has the value of
messages the tab messages will be
highlighted or the nav link will be
highlighted so each time we click one we
want to change the active item name
to that to the name of that
menu item if that makes sense
i think it does all right so
we need to say this is either a const or
a function i'm just going to keep it as
an arrow function like that but the
difference here instead of setting state
we're going to say
set
active item and just pass it this name
so that it changes it
and we don't need a render because this
is a functional component we just return
and we need to remove this parent curly
brace here
i'm going to remove this segment i'm not
going to have any image remove this wrap
in div
just keep the menu
and here we don't need to import segment
we just need menu so we've set up our
navbar but of course we don't want
messages and friends and logout we want
um so the first one we want it to be the
home so we will give it a name home and
the active
uh will be will be active when it's home
and here we don't pass the on click
event will be this handle click but we
don't give it this dot because this is
not a
class-based component anymore we just
pass it like that and here we'll have
we have a
login
tab or nav link and this will be login
as well
and actually i want the login and the
logout button or the register button to
be on the right so i'm going to put put
it inside of this
other menu that's positioned on the
right
so that's the login that's fine and
instead of logout we'll have register
here register make sure to change this
one as well
okay let's save let's see what this
looks like but we're not going to see it
because we have we haven't used it here
so let's say here import
menu bar from
components
slash menu bar
and we're going to put it at the top
here
so
menu bar so it's going to be on the page
regardless of what what page we're in
all right let's save everything let's
make sure our app is running without any
errors it's compiling all right it runs
successfully let's look at our app
let's refresh
okay there's a problem on click this
handle effect oh did i not save
i did
oh yeah i thought i removed this this
this okay
now it should work
all right so we get the menu
but it's huge so let's put everything in
a container uh so we go back to the
semantic ui the container where is it
uh
right here all right what's cool about
this documentation is that you can see
as well what it renders eventually so uh
let's use it and i want to show you
something as well so we'll just copy
that
and let's go in the app or close this
terminal window
and here we'll say import container from
semantic ui react and let's wrap
everything let's cut everything and wrap
it in a container component
so tab and put everything inside
and let's look at our app
we have two home buttons let's fix that
so here
um let's remove this
and save
all right so we get our buttons uh none
of them is active but if you click one
it becomes active but we're not browsing
to different pages
but i want to show you something quickly
so we got the container right but don't
forget at the end of the day we've
linked the css so we can actually just
here just replace this container with
div
and give it a class name
of
ui container because if you look at the
documentation at the end of the day it's
just going to render a ui container i
did with a class ui container which
tells um our css that you know which
tells our page that this is from
the semantic ui css and in fact we have
the same effect here but just don't
forget with semantic ui you have to
always have this ui thing if you just
say div dot container it's not going to
work all right we're just going to
revert back to using the
container component just wanted to show
you that
and
here
we want these to be links so these menu
items what's cool about these components
from a semantic ui react it's an
integration so we can still say as and
we can have it as a different um
component
we can have it behave as a different
component as well and we want it to
behave as a link so we want to import
that so let's say import
link
from
brow to dom and here we want it to
behave as link so here we can uh pass
the
props that will be on the link which
would we just need two so this is the
home we want it to go to just slash
let's copy these two and paste them here
this will go to slash
login
because
those pages are there if we so if you go
to login slash login we will see that
the login page is there it's just that
they're not linked
let's go back so this will go to slash
login and this will go to slash register
like this let's save all files
and let's look at our app
all right so we get the navigation but
the home initially is not active all
right so the way we can solve this is
that
what i wanted to do is i wanted to be by
default on the home and then when we
click it changes
so
we can start by saying home here use
state home
and it starts there and if we go there
to any other page it goes to that one
and as well it highlights that one
let's make these buttons bigger
and let's go here so in our menu
we can i think we can yeah we have a
property size and by the way you can do
control space and you can um scroll up
you can see all the properties that you
can add of course you can see them on
the documentation uh here we have a
property size and we have these sizes i
think the biggest is massive
and i want to give a um a color as well
to the active item of teal
let's save
let's look alright so there for some
reason like the biggest size is actually
not that big but that's fine that's fine
by me the those are big enough all right
so it's got this cool teal color um one
thing that we need to fix though if you
just go to the page slash login like
this
it's not gonna highlight login it's just
gonna it's not it's just gonna set the
home as active so what we want to do is
we want to each time the menu bar loads
it it looks at the link that we're at
and the temp
there depending on this link we actually
set the link active so if this link says
login we set this active if this link
says slash register we set this to
active
so let's go to our menu bar
and
here we can say
const path name and we can get this just
from the javascript from the window
object
this is just javascript window.location
and the path
name
and depending on where we we're at this
can uh this can be just slash this can
be slash about whatever page you're in
so
uh the way we're gonna determine that
we're in the homepage it's not gonna be
slash home it's just gonna be slash so
we're gonna check for that so here we'll
have another variable called
just path
and we'll say if path name so we'll do a
ternary operator
equals
just slash then we want to set the path
to the word home
else so colon um what do we do yeah okay
so what we do here is that we have slash
about for example or slash login because
that's more the case in our app we don't
want it to set it to a slash login
because though that will confuse these
items and they will not be active we
just want this so we can use the
javascript function substring so we'll
say path name
dot sub
dot
sub string or actually just sub sdr
and
we can start at a
an index we want to start at the index
one which is this one and we want to get
the rest of the string so just leave it
like that
so if it's login it's just going to take
this without taking the slash and it's
going to set it to that page now we want
to as well set the active item to that
path so we want to pass it to our use
date
and of course this will come after
this logic right here
all right let me remove this comment and
save and this should work
all right it works so if we go to slash
login it
it sets that to active and if we go to
slash
register
it says that to active and if we change
them they do change and the page
actually changes all right so that's
that with setting the routes and
implementing semantic ui
hello class welcome to part three of
this series i mean class three i don't
know what part is i'm trying to have a
theme here
by the way if you've reached this file
and especially if you've done the server
code as well give credit to yourself
seriously you're in the one percent of
people that are trying to improve and
kind of improve their skills and learn
more stuff you're like this guy right
here you are the hero on a
self-actualization and self-development
journey
all right so enough of that and let's
actually write some code okay so here in
the uh
merge folder
i'm actually not going to open the whole
folder anymore i'm just going to open
the client folder because we don't need
to write
any server code anymore so it's less to
look at on the left side so i'm going to
see the one level back and i'm going to
say npm run serve to run the server and
i'll open a new tab what is this go away
and here i'll say npm start to start the
client
so here in the home page it's currently
empty just says
all right it's currently empty it just
says home page uh let's let's actually
use some query the get posts query and
fetch them and show them on this page
i'm going to open uh close this client
the terminal so it doesn't take space
uh here we'll need the
use query hook use
query
we're going to get that from
apollo react hooks and actually we need
to install a couple things so let me
open a new tab new terminal tab and here
we'll say npm install make sure again
you're in the client folder and we'll
install graph
graphql and graph
graphql
dash tag like this
and here let's get the graphql tag let's
say import and the convention is to call
it gql from
uh graphql
and uh here we need to write this
graphql query that we're gonna
you know we're gonna use or we're going
to
i don't even know what you do to a
graphql
query all right so here we'll call this
fetch
underscore
uh posts underscore query
here we'll say g equals gql
and we'll put our uh our query here and
it's the get posts query
and we're going to get uh
essentially everything so we'll get the
id we'll get the body
we get the created ad
and we'll get the username
and we get the like count
and from the likes as well we'll get so
let's do like this we'll get the
username of
of the person that liked we'll get the
comment count
and we'll get from comments
array we'll get the id username
and created ad
and the body of the comment all right
um by the way i've mentioned this before
if you want syntax highlighting instead
of the gql tag template you can get this
graphql for vs code extension and that
will do that for you all right let's
save let it format
what is it not format
of course because i need to wrap this in
a query tag so do like that and then
save all right cool
so here we'll um
we'll um actually run this query so
we'll say
uh const
and from use query we get a couple of
things
from them there is loading which is true
when we're actually loading and there's
data
and which has the data so here we'll say
equals use query and then we'll pass it
our fetch posts query and yeah that's it
so here we can just say if data so we
have if we have data we can say uh
console.log data so we'll see what we
get so let's save this let's actually
close this terminal because taking too
much space or let me close it
all right so there's a problem here
graphql does not contain
uh oh because it's from graphql tag not
graphql
let's go back
let's open up our console
and there we go we get an object and
it's got four posts all right and our
posts are stored in the get posts object
because that's how queries and mutations
work so what we can do we can um just
destructure that so from that we get um
get posts and we can even give it an
alias which is just post because it
makes more sense
so here what we need to do we need to
iterate through these posts and show
them and for this i'm going to use the
semantic ui okay we're here
where is it
we need we need the grid i'm going to
use a 3 grid 3 column grid layout so we
can just copy this
grid tag
from here let's go to our home
i'll paste this here
and we need to close the grid
component
let's remove these uh
three or two columns and here we need to
import that so we need to say import
grid
from
semantic ui react
i'm going to remove the divided because
i don't want that divider line and here
i'm going to put another row at the top
to put like a title of the page
and here we'll say
put a header one and say recent
posts
and here we'll have another row under
that row and this will have a column but
actually
let's cut this column
and inside of this row we want to check
if we're loading because i want to add
like a loading spinner thing
and if we're loading so if that's true
we do a ternary operator and here for
now i'm just gonna put a header one and
say loading posts dot dot
and then here we'll put colon so else
then uh we're gonna actually iterate
through our posts so here we'll say uh
and the thing is by the way we could
this can be null or undefined because
data itself is not uh populated so we
need to check for it first if it's
truthy so we'll say if post so posts and
end now we can loop through them so
we'll say post
dot
map and for each post
actually what's up oh actually we don't
need this because we're already in a
javascript block so we can say for each
post
we want to return the following
and uh here we will paste that column
back but we're not gonna have an image
and inside of here we can put everything
that relates to the post but of course
we're gonna let's put this in its own
component so that we'll have smaller
components and uh you know better
modularity so here i'll call this
postcard because we haven't created it
yet and let's pass it the post so we'll
pass it a property called post with the
value of this post
all right let's close this and uh
because we're iterating through and in
react when we iterate through we need to
give a key value to our topmost
component or key attribute
and this will be the post id because
that's unique so we don't have to worry
about non-unique keys
let's remove this if data console log
data
and let's save this of course this is
going to have an error because we don't
have a postcard yet
let's import it and then create it so
we'll say import postcard from
we put it in components so we go back
one level we go to components slash post
card like this
let's create that so post
card dot js
and here we'll import
react
and we'll import
a couple of things from semantic ui so
we'll have the card
we'll have the icon
and we'll have the label
i think that's it for now from semantic
ui
css react
and here we'll say function
post card
and we'll get the props because we're
passing some props down here we need to
say export default
postcard
and
here we will
say return
before we turn we need to get our
properties so we can say const
so we're going to get the body we're
going to get the created add we're going
to get
what else id
username
body oh we got body already
what do we get like count yeah
and
so we need to get comment count
count like that
and the likes
all right i think that's it let me look
back
likes
yeah that's it common count and like
count yeah that's fine so we get them
from props dot uh post
or actually
let's just copy all of this we can
destructure it straight away inside of
here so here we'll say from
props
and from post
we're gonna destructor all of this so we
don't need to do this expression here
all right so here we will return a card
and
actually we can just copy one card from
here just go
i have to type everything when it's
already here i want something that looks
like this i want to get the molly one
let's get the second one so all of this
card tag copy that
our card component
all right so here we have our card card
content floated right that's fine
uh actually yeah that's fine i want to
leave that image uh but here instead of
this relative path we need to get the
actual path of that or the the link to
that image so let's do this let's get
that link copy it and let's paste it
here
all right so the header is not molly
thomas it's actually the username of
whoever posted this post so here we'll
put the username
and here the the meta will be the
created at date so here but the created
add date right now is a iso string so we
need to format it so let's open a new
terminal tab and install moment so let's
say npm install moment
and give that a moment to install hahaha
so here we'll say import moment
from
moment
and um
here in the meta we'll say moment
and we'll pass it the created ad oops
what is that created add and here we'll
say dot from now
which
which we'll do like kind of like an hour
ago or five hours ago etc
so here let's um in the description this
is the body of the card we'll just say
body which is the body of the post
and here let's remove this stuff and
because we're gonna have some different
buttons here let's just put a paragraph
saying buttons
here
and
let's save everything
see if there's no
there's something wrong
oh okay i did i just didn't save
i didn't save when i added this import
line at the top
okay let's close this
okay image is not defined
oh yeah because we didn't import image
so here image from symantec ui
all right cool so we get our posts and
um
they don't have any margin between them
so let's fix that so here let's go back
here to the home
uh this column right here let's give it
some inline styling just say
margin
bottom
let's give it 20 pixels
save that
uh cool we got some margin bottom
and
okay so i want to remove this ago
because obviously if it's to two hours
that means it's two hours ago we can do
that by here in the from now we can by
default it passes it false we'll pass it
through and it will remove that ago all
right so just two hours two hours and
the thing is these cards are not taking
the um the full width of uh of the
container div
or not the container i mean this uh
column div
so what we need to do
so here in the card we can just add this
property called fluid which will let
them take up more space cool all right
they look better now
let's make just like facebook let's make
this um timestamp a link into the post
itself
so here
for this uh card meta we're going to say
as
and it's going to be a link
i'm going to give it a property too and
this let's do a backticks and we'll say
slash posts slash dollar sign curly
braces and here we'll put the id of the
post of course we need to import link as
well so let's import
link
from react
router
dom
and let's save let's look at it all
right so this becomes a link and it
takes us there of course there's nothing
here all right cool so this takes us to
that id etc etc
all right so let's actually add these
buttons the like and comment buttons
so
the way i want to do it i want to use
this button right here whereas
button
button button
yeah button here
i should have opened it already
so i want to use this button i think it
looks sick
so here let's uh copy this first button
right here
and here in the extra div
let's paste it and of course that's the
import button from from semantic ui we
already have label and icon installed i
mean imported
and here in this button is going to be
as div label position right that's fine
but i want this to be a teal because
it's the like button
and i'm going to leave it as a heart and
i don't want it to say like because
that's kind of self-explanatory
and here we'll have a label it's not
going to be an anchor tag so we'll
remove that the color will be teal
and instead of this just hard coded
value we'll have a number and this will
be the like count
let's save let's see what this looks
like
cool it looks uh but it looks like as if
we already liked it so i want it to be
just um
kind of outline only so i think yeah
this button right here i think we just
need to add it
yeah yeah it's just we add basic here
all right cool it's uh just outlined
because i wanted to because of course we
need to later implement when we log in
or uh when we're logged in that we can
like but when we're logged out i want it
to be kind of um
outlined like this and when we click it
it takes us to the login page right now
when we click it it doesn't do anything
actually let's add a on click button
event
so here we'll say on click
equals
let's call this function like post
and let's create that right here say
function
like post
of course for now it's just going to
console.log
like post
like that
and we want as well another button for
the comment for comments so let's cut
that and paste copy and paste it so div
that's fine right on click it's going to
say comment
on
post
we can create that as well so here we'll
say
function
comment on post it's just gonna
console.log
um
comment on
post
so here we have comment on post we have
a button but the this button i want it
to be blue
and the icon is to be comments
and the label is going to be
of color blue and basic that's fine
pointing left and here we will have the
uh comment count and not the like count
all right let's save all right we get
the uh
this is interesting actually this is a
different icon
i think i'm meant to type comment not
comments
yeah okay i was using this icon but
actually i prefer the new icon because
it has multiple comments instead of just
one okay yeah cool so now we're showing
the actual comment count and the like
count and we're showing these two
buttons of course they don't do anything
right now they they just print some
some logs to our console but of course
we need to implement this functionality
later to have them do stuff but uh
that's gonna come after we handle
authentication because of course we need
to be logged in for us to be able to
like and comment on posts one thing i
want to fix though is this um title this
recent post so i want to put it in the
middle and have some margin to the top
so let's go to the home
right here let's give this a class so
here this row let's give it a class name
and let's call this page dash title
let's go to our app.css say page title
and let's give it a display
block
and let's say text
text align center
and let's say font size let's give it
some font size uh some bigger font size
of two ram
and some margin top as well margin
top
of
10 pixels
let's save let's save all files
um
all right there's something wrong
okay let's look at here
i don't know here
okay the display block is not being
applied because it's being overridden by
the dot row uh we can just simply say um
uh we can add the important
thing to it
yeah okay now it's fixed all right
that's just these minor effects that i
wanted to do in the next video we're
going to work on logging in and
registering users so look forward to
that
hey class and welcome back i have
nothing cringey to say in this intro so
let's just get to it all right so in the
last class we fetched all our posts and
showed them on the home page so it'd be
nice to actually now have a login and a
registered form so let's do just that
all right let's go to our app
and here in the
register component we're going to use a
form so let's say up here import form
from
symantec ui react and the waveform works
if you go to the semantic ui react
documentation is that you just put a
form and inside of it you put a form
field and then inside of that you can
put a label and then an input with all
the props that you wanted to have or the
attributes but there's another way which
is better in my opinion to do is that
you just have a form input here and you
put all those props inside of just this
one component so we'll use that approach
so here inside of the
div here
instead of saying just a header one we
put a form so let's say form
and then we'll have an on submit
which is on
submit which we haven't created yet but
we will
and we will say as well no
validate because html5 by default tries
to validate email
fields so here we'll say we'll have a
header one saying register
and here we'll have our first form field
so we'll say form dot
field or input rather
and here we'll say actually will not
close it we'll have a couple of
attributes here we'll have a label for
the register and it will
actually this is the first for a field
which is going to be the um
the username field so we'll have a label
saying username
and we'll have a placeholder
saying username like this
actually this needs to be capital uh u
as well
uh we'll have a name which we'll use to
identify what field this is when we're
like changing and submitting stuff so
this will be username like that
and we'll have a value
i'm going to give this actually we can
initialize this right now so we'll say
const
and we'll have values
and we'll have set values
equals use state
and it's going to be um
this these uh default values will be a
username
we'll have an empty string and we'll
have
a password
which is an empty string we'll have an
email
which is an empty string and we'll have
a
confirm password
which is an empty string as well okay
this doesn't make a sense in terms of
order doesn't matter that much but i
just like to keep it kind of
the same order that i'll put to the
fields all right so here we'll have the
value would be value.username or
values.username
and here we'll have
an on change so on change
will be
on change which we'll create in a moment
so let's close this so this is our first
input let's copy this
three more times one two three
so the second one will be the email so
the label will say email
the placeholder will say email
the name will say email and i should
have ctrl d but i'll do in the next one
the values as well values.email so here
let's click here and ctrl d once and say
password
and the name click here and ctrl d1 and
say password like this with a lowercase
p
and here let's click here
and say
confirm
password
like this
and here this will be confirm password
like that
and of course we need a button for
submitting this form so we'll have a
button
this is a semantic ui button so we need
to import it in a second so this will be
of type submit because it's a form and
let's give it the
the primary attribute so that it becomes
blue and you will say register
let's go up here we need to bring button
and we also need to import uh use state
from react because we're using it so
we'll say use state like that
let's now write these uh um on on submit
and on change so it will say um
const
on change
equals we'll take an event
and it will
it's just going to set a set to the
values
but remember here we need to spread our
existing values otherwise it's just
going to override it with one key value
attribute
pair and here we need to get
event dot target
dot name this is going to be the name of
the field because it's going to be this
name right here
and
event dot target dot value to give it
that to to give you the value of that
all right so that's that for unchanged
now we need the on submit so here we'll
say const on submit
submit
equals it's going to take the event
and we're going to
first of course prevent default so
prevent
default
and here we need to um
check and send our actually we don't
check we're not going to do any client
side validation because we already have
our server side validation so we need to
straight away send a mutation to our
server and uh persist these users if the
data is valid so here we actually will
actually write our
graphql mutation so here we'll say const
register
user
and it will be gql
we need to import this as well so we'll
say mutation
uh register
and this will take a couple of variables
so it will take a username of type
string and that's required we can just
copy this just to be like quick so three
more times so we'll have a an email
a a password
a confirm
password
and here so after this we'll say like
that and this will trigger the register
mutation which takes a register input if
from if you remember our server code and
this will have a couple of things and
this will have a username it's the same
it's the same thing but we need to give
them as variables here
so username and we can just copy this
three more times
and here will be an email
here will be the password
and here will be the oops i need to ctrl
d and say confirm
password
all right so after this is triggered we
need to get a couple of fields back so
we'll get all of them so the id the
email the username the created
ad and of course most importantly the uh
the token the jwt token of course we
need to import gql so let's go up here
we'll say
import
gql
from
graphql tag
and uh we need to as well the use
mutation hook so we'll say import
use
mutation
from
uh at apollo slash react hooks not
common hooks
all right so here we'll say let's remove
this white space and we'll say const
oops const
and we'll get a couple of things from
here from this so
we'll use a radius structuring and let's
call this a function add user
and we'll have a couple of things from
here but we'll just get the loading
and here we'll say equals use mutation
and we'll pass it our register user
mutation and here for the um
for the options we'll have a function
called update
and this will be triggered if the
mutation is successfully um executed so
this will give us two um a couple of
things the proxy that this will we will
rarely use it's got some metadata and
here we'll have a result this will hold
the result of the mutation so here let's
just console.log the result for now and
see what happens
and um
i think yeah this is it for now oh we
also we need to give the um the
variables because this is a mutation we
need to give some variables
of the mutations we can all we can do
here so username is
values.username and then attach the
other three but since the object of
values is the same this that is those
values that we want to send we can just
say variables is values simple as that
and now of course we need to trigger
this add user function
when we submit our form but the thing is
we can't just put it here and we can't
put this
um above here or can we well actually we
can yeah we can just put this above here
and so we have access to the add user
yeah so you can just add user like this
and that will work
all right let's um i think this is it
let's save
let's make sure that we have no errors
here
we don't cool
it says that we're not using loading but
we'll use it in a second all right so
let's look at our form all right it's
way too wide let's um let's fix that
so here
for our wrapping div we can give it a
class name
of
form
container
or container like this
and let's go to our app.css
here we'll say
dot form
dash container
and we can just say
width is
400 pixels
and let's give it a margin auto so it's
pushed to the middle
auto let's save let's save all files
all right it looks much better now okay
let's open up the console window put
them side by side and see what happens
if we just send yeah if we just send a
form empty like that we get uh errors we
can't see them here but they're actually
encapsulated in the errors object that
we can get from this but if we register
a new user successfully let's say new
let's give some valid data so new and
new email.com
and here we'll say one through six
and
oh actually i forgot to say this is of
type password so let's quickly change
that
so here this uh these passwords are
where are they oh i didn't even give the
type actually so let's give the type to
these
[Music]
just for good measure so this one will
be type this is the username type text
just copy this here we can just give a
type of email
and for the password we'll give a type
of password
and we can just copy this one more time
and give it to the confirm password a
type of password as well
all right
let's look at our app now if we type
something here it's um it's hidden so
here we'll say new and the email will be
new at email.com
and the password will be one through six
and the confirm password will be the
same thing
and we hit enter there we go we get data
back which holds a data object
which holds a register object because
that's the name of the mutation and we
get exactly the fields we want all right
that's brilliant but what we want to do
is we want to redirect to the home page
once the user is registered successfully
and we want to use that loading loading
boolean when we send some data we want
it to see like spinning
that's really easy with semantic ui
what we can do let's go to our form here
we can give it a class name
and if the class name is loading it's
going to be it's going to have a spinner
in the middle so here we'll have a
actually a dynamic value and we'll say
if loading it's the loading that we got
from the user mutation
then we give it a class of loading
else we give it like just an empty class
like that all right let's save
let's go to our app
and here you can see briefly the
the loading spinner comes for a second
and then goes because like the response
comes way too fast but it does have a
loading effect
all right so what we need to do now is
we need to handle um errors because we
can we can get some errors from our
request and we need to show them on our
form so here
after the update i'm going to say on
error
which is this other function or
other function that we have and it holds
the error and here we'll say
um
we will say actually what do we do oh we
need to actually have some errors in our
component and then we set them here if
they exist so here we'll say const and
we'll have errors
like this and we'll have a set
errors
function equals
use state and we'll pass this an empty
object like that
and inside of here so if we get errors
we just want to say set errors
let's put a comma here
and these will be inside of error dot
graph
ql errors i get some autocomplete
because i typed it before but here
graphql errors you can return multiple
errors but the way our server code is is
written is that we get we give one error
and inside of that there's an object
that holds all those errors so we will
access the first error like this in this
array and we say dot extensions
extensions which is this object that's
inside of it dot exception
exception
and here we've we have put our errors if
you remember
when we wrote this code in our server
code
so here we set those errors to these
errors and we can actually console log
them just to make sure that these this
is what we're looking for so here we'll
say console.log and we console.log
exactly that and then we set it to our
errors
but of course we need to show them on
our markup
so i didn't find a way how to do this
with semantic ui react but so i'm just
going to use the semantic ui css because
we have access to that as well so here
we'll have a um a div
or just like this dot ui dot error dot
message
and here we need to put a ul with a
class of list
and here we need to to loop through our
errors and access them but the way our
errors work is we get a key called for
example username and then we get an
error called username must not be empty
so we don't need the keys we just need
to show the errors so what we need to do
is object dot
values
so we access the values and not the keys
of errors because we have that in our
state or like set state variable
dot map and we map through them so for
each value
we want to display an ally so we just do
like this parenthesis and we'll display
an ally since we're iterating through an
array we need to say we need to give it
an key because we're in react and this
key will be the value because these are
unique
and here we'll say and the what it
contains as well is the value of this
error and of course this is conditional
because we might not have errors at all
so let's cut that and here we'll say
we can if we check to if we just have
errors it will be truthy because we have
errors all the time and it's an empty
object at the beginning so what we need
to check we need to check if this errors
has any keys so we'll say object dot
keys
of errors
dot length
bigger than zero so if the length of it
is bigger than zero then there is some
keys and that means we have some errors
so let's show this so we'll say and and
and we put parentheses and we put
everything back in here
all right so let's save that
and let's go to our app okay let's
submit an empty form and right now we
should get an error for username for
email and for password as well
and we do so a username must not be
empty email must not be empty and
password must not be empty but let's
invalidate these as well because it
makes more sense to see the ones that
are not valid invalidated we can simply
do that by
um so in the field we'll add this error
property so error property which is a
boolean so it's either true or false but
here we'll give it a dynamic value so
for username we're going to check for
errors dot username
and if that's truthy so
we'll give we'll put a ternary operator
and say true else it's false there's no
error for username so let's copy this
paste it here for email and change oops
change this to email
let's paste it for the password and
change it to password
and let's put it to the confirm password
and change it to confirm password
let's save that
let's look at our form let's make it
full screen
and here let's say
so let's have no username and let's put
a valid uh email so
new at email.com and put like i'll put
one through six and then here put one
through
seven
so there we go it says username must not
be empty and passwords must match so
let's fix that that's fixed you get just
username and if i put new here and say
register just press enter
actually the username is taken because
we registered that new
new user so here we can say new to
and the regis oh it says username is
taken do i have new tool as well
okay so i have a new and i have a new
two in the database so i'm just gonna
delete those for now and test again
let's delete this as well or is it
yeah oh that's confusing news here let's
delete that oh actually one thing i
forgot
um so here
once we submit and it's successful and
we add a user on the update here once we
get our successful result we need to
redirect to the home page so here we'll
say props
dot props dot
history
push and we'll just push the slash which
is the home uh homepage and of course we
need to take our props as well from the
parent component
all right so let's save that
proxy we don't need to use it so we can
omit it and just put an underscore here
so let's uh
let's go to our app right here
and here let's put some valid data so we
deleted that new user so we can use this
again so let's say new
at email.com and let's put one through
six one through six
register
there we go you get a cool spinner and
we are logged in
and we go to the home page and we get
this token back now of course we're not
putting this token in any application
state or anything for now but the
register is working and it's sending a
request and we're successfully
registering this user
and if we check there we go new at
email.com all right let's do the same
for the login
page as well so what we need to do is
actually we can copy everything from
here from the register page and we go to
the login component and paste everything
here actually one thing that i want to
do is let's put this
this
on change and the on submit let's put
them in a custom hook because otherwise
we're repeating the same code across two
components
so let's copy this um
actually let's open up the
the side here let's put a create a new
file inside a folder called util so util
slash hooks and here we'll keep our
custom hooks
so from the login we can copy the
onchange
and here let's uh
import we'll need use state because we
want to store the values here as well
from react
and here we'll say
const
export const i've written this hook for
the
custom hook video that i have so you
might be familiar with it so this will
be
it will take a callback and i'll explain
what this does in a second
and it will take an initial
state
and this will be by default an empty
object and you will do the following
and here we'll have let's let's paste
that and then let's copy as well this
values from here or like this
from here
and um
spaced it here but this will be actually
the initial state so here in the login
actually in the register
let's fix the register first so here
we'll say const
initial
state equals that
and here in the hook if we take an
initial state and then we and you use
state and we pass it the initial state
like that and the own change will be i
think the same
yeah it's the same so we get an event
and we set values these values to that
that's fine and then we'll have the on
submit so we'll say const on submit
take an event and it will oops
it will
event dot prevent default
oops i misspelled default like that
and here it will call that callback
because the thing is we don't uh
depending on what page this used form is
used in the callback can be different
right i know in our case it's not but we
make it more generic by passing this
callback and then calling it from here
now of course we need to return these
values and the on change in the on
submit so that we can use them in the in
the component so we'll say return and we
turn an object with the onchange
the onsubmit
and the values like that all right so
our hook is done let's save it
and here in the register let's import
that hook so here we'll say import
uh what is it called used for
actually
because it's not the default we need to
do like that
from go back one level to util slash
hooks
so here we don't need to say this like
that
we just need to extract those so we'll
say const
and we'll get the on change
the on submit
and the values
from use form
so this will take a callback uh let's
give it the add add user
function as the callback and let's give
it the initial state which is going to
be this so let's copy what's inside of
this initial state
we can just pass it like that without
actually declaring a variable here
so here we have those we have the on
change in the on submit so we can just
remove this and we can remove this
so but the problem here of course the
the add user is not recognized up here
but as well if we take this and we put
it underneath here the values up here
will not be recognized because they're
coming from here so a workaround around
this is
we can declare a function here say
function
let's call it register user
and this will simply just call the add
user
uh function which we get from here and
then we can pass this as uh this
callback right here now you might be
wondering what the hell why does this
not be um not be recognized up here but
this will but the way javascript works
is that all the functions with a keyword
function in front of them at the
beginning of the program are hoisted
meaning that they are brought up and
kind of read through initially and then
even if it's down here but it has the
function keyword it's actually
recognized up here
unlike the const
variable functions all right so this
should be fine
let's we didn't actually see our console
log errors but of course
seeing the result of what happened we
are getting the pro the proper error so
we can remove these console logs
and let's uh save everything
do we not yeah we don't have any errors
let's check let's make sure that
everything works the same in a login
form
so we go here
all right cool so everything works the
same the on submit is working
and as well if we submit some valid uh
data so you will say i don't know some
just random email
for now and put one through six
there we go registered and we're
redirected to the home page so the the
hook is working fine now we need to
integrate it in the login form so here
let's import it so let's say import
use form
from
and go back one level to
util slash hooks
and here this is login not register
oops log
in
and here we have the errors the same way
we'll have a const and this will be
let's call it login user
and this will call a mutation of a login
user which we'll create in a second
and update
it will let's not
console.log that we will push to the
home page the same way and we will set
the errors the same way nothing changes
here and the on submit is the same
except it's gonna call uh what is it
gonna call it's gonna call the login
user
from here
and then
actually no we don't have a lot on
submit we're going to use the
use form hook excuse me so here we'll
have the on change
the on
submit
and we'll have the values
from
use
form
and i'll call back so let's make this
the callback so here we'll say
function
uh login
user since we already have a login user
let's just call this login user callback
like that
and it will only it will simply call the
login user
so we'll pass it here as the callback in
the login form and the initial state
will be a username so we only have a
username and a password on the login
form it's going to be an empty username
and the password will be an empty
password so the login user will do that
we'll call that and we'll get
we'll do the same thing the callback all
right so here in our markup
we have a form same thing same uh
stuff here but for the header we'll say
login
and for the input we'll have just two
inputs so here let's remove this
let's keep the password input and remove
the email input
so here we'll have a username the same
stuff nothing changes and the password
as well the same stuff nothing changes
so here in the button we'll say login
instead of register
and here for errors nothing changes as
well
but here instead of register user we'll
have a login
user
and here we'll have the mutation of
login and we will remove the email and
we'll remove the confirm password
and here we'll have the
mutation
login and we don't have a register input
so we can remove that like this like
this
and we can remove the email
and we can do the password like that
we can remove this
and we'll get the same data as well from
the login mutation all right let's save
everything
let's check if this is working we have
no errors or we have an error so
register is not defined
oh because i'm exporting register at the
bottom all right so here we will export
login let's save
all right cool no errors let's check our
app
all right login form we get this form
and if we log in with empty it says
username must not be empty and if we put
a username
it says password must not be empty if we
put the wrong password so i'll put 137
click login it loads and then it says
wrong credentials but if i put the
correct credentials one through six i
click enter and voila we are logged in
and we get redirected to the homepage
now of course we're not changing the
navbar right here because we still have
those buttons because we don't have an
actually application-wide kind of
context that knows that we're logged in
or not which we will do in the next
class so look forward to that
i shouldn't have had the third coffee
coders problems eh
okay whatever let's do this
hello class and welcome to class five uh
so we've done a lot so far we have
created the login and registered pages
and they redirect us to the homepage if
we log in successfully or register
successfully but the caveat is we're not
doing anything with this data right now
because if we log in if i just type in
some valid credentials we just receive
some data from our server but we're not
doing anything with it because for
example you can see that our
navbar is still saying login and
register so we need a way to store this
user data globally in our application so
that whenever a component needs to know
whether we're logged in or not
whether we need some permission to do
some behavior that's only allowed when
we're logged in so that needs to access
it aka a global state which we can do
through either context or redux or
through uh some other stuff we're going
to use context because this app is too
small for redux because
we're only going to manage some user
data that's it so
let's actually start to make that a
reality
all right so let's go to our app
here i'm going to create a new file
inside of a folder called context
so call it auth.js because it's going to
be our auth context
so here we'll import
react oops react
from react
so what we're going to create we're
going to create in a context so we'll
just
actually create this context actually i
forgot to
get create context from react and here
we'll say const auth
context equals create
context
context
and here we'll
so we'll pass a couple of things our
context will hold a user object and
initially this will be null
and here we'll have a login
uh function and this will take some data
and we'll do something this is just like
kind of a placeholder to have like
some sort of like intelligence later
it's not uh it's not necessary you can
actually emit these two but it's a good
practice i think and we'll have a logout
which will take nothing and do something
all right so here what we need to create
is we need to create a reducer and
if you don't know about a reducer i
suggest you get familiar with the
patterns of redux and uh and then you
will know what a reducer is i'm not
gonna like kind of go in depth it's
basically it receives uh an action with
a type and a payload and then it
determines what to do with those two
depending on your
functionality of your application so
here we'll have a reducer and we'll call
it uh auth reducer
oops reducer like this
and this will take like i said the state
actually i didn't mention that it takes
the state because it needs to uh change
the state
and an action and it will switch on the
action
dot state so on um or rather the dot
type not state so depending on the type
of the action it's going to do something
of course any switch needs a default
case and in the default case we're just
going to return the state
okay state like this
now we'll have another case here usually
you'd have like you'd put them in
variables but we only have two so i'm
just going to have them as strings here
uh one i'll call login like this
and
when we log in we need to return of
course we spread the existing state and
we want to add the user
so because we're logging in and we're
getting some data and we want to set our
user in our state to this data so we'll
say action user equals action.payload
now i'll have another case
which is
case logout so here we'll say log out
like this
so when we log out we simply want to
clear the data we want to set the user
back to null
so here we'll spread the state oops
spread the state and say user is null
all right so of course we need to use
this reducer somewhere and we'll use it
in our auth provider so here we'll
create a an auth provider so function
auth
context pro
vita like this
and this will take a props and i'll tell
you later why it takes a props take some
props so here we'll say const state
and dispatch actually we need to get
user
the user reducer hook use
reducer
and the user reducer hook takes a
reducer and returns
a state and a dispatch and we need to as
well give it um so we'll say reuse
reducer we need to
give it our reducer so the auth reducer
and we need to give it an initial state
which is going to be a user
of null
but this is our initial state so now
that we have our this dispatch we can
use it to uh dispatch any action and
then attach to it uh some type and a
payload and then that when that's
dispatched this reducer will listen to
it and then do um you know perform any
action according to that dispatched
action so here we need to actually write
our login and log out functions so that
will pass them down to our component
tree so here we'll say const login
and
so the login is just a function that
will take some data and actually
since i'm using the keyword function a
lot in this project i'm just going to
stick to that so i'll say function login
takes data
and here what he needs to do is just
gonna
dispatch um
it's a action with a type
of login
and a payload oops
a payload
of this data that you got
well actually it would make sense more
sense if we name this user data because
we'll know what what it is and we can as
well here change it to user data even
though it doesn't matter it's just a an
argument name but
but it's more readable like this
all right so here we want to have our
logout function as well so function
logout
and here our logout will actually won't
take anything and it will dispatch
an action with a type
um
log out and this will not have any
payload because that's how logout works
all right so here we need to return this
provider so we can use it somewhere else
so here we'll say return and we'll open
a component and say auth
context
dot provider
and now we need to have a value because
this is what we need to pass what this
is what we're going to pass to our
components that are underneath this
context provider so here our value will
be a javascript object so we wrap it in
two curly braces so we'll say uh user
is the state.user so we need to pass the
user down
and here we'll pass the login function
and the logout function as well
and here we'll do we'll spread props
like this
because we might get some props from the
top down component and now we need to
export
two things we need to export our auth
context
because that's what we're going to use
from our components to access our
context and we need to um
export the auth provider which will use
in our app to wrap all of our
applications so that it would have
access to this uh provider to these
functions from the context all right so
this is what's going to happen when we
log in we want to call the login
function or this dispatch this login
type with this data which will change
the data inside of our context and set
our user to the user details that we
have so that our application will know
that we're logged in all right first
thing before we go to any login or
register page we need to actually give
our application this provider so here
we'll say
import
auth
provider
from
uh so from util or not util actually
from all context
slash auth
so here we'll wrap our entire um
so we'll cut this and we'll say auth
not context provider
and do like this and put everything
inside of that so everything inside of
here will have access to that
to that context all right so first
things first we need to go to login and
here once we're logged in so we get our
login data inside of this
result.data.login object so we need
to
hit this login function and actually
pass it this data so that our context
will set the user to uh to the actual
user data so we need to get that context
so here we'll say import
ask context
from we go back one level and we go to
context
slash auth like this and we need the use
context hook so here we'll say use
context from react and here at the top
of our component we'll say const
actually let me close this
const
context equals
use context
and we give it the auth context that we
imported and now we have access to that
context and remember this this context
holds a user a login and a logout so we
need this login right here so here
before we redirect to the home page once
we successfully log in we simply say
context dot
login and we pass it the data which is
going to be a result.data.login
right here
right right here it kind of doesn't make
a lot of sense to have it called login
so what we can do we can from result we
can destructure data and from data we
can destructure login and login we need
we can give it an alias and let's call
this user data now we can just pass user
data right here
oops what did i copy
so we can just pass user data right here
which makes so much more sense than just
passing result data login okay we can
remove this console log because we know
we're getting the correct data and let's
do the exact same thing from the um from
the register component so we go to the
register component and
here at the top we got our context so we
can say import
auth
context
from we go back oops we go back one
level to context slash auth
and of course we need to use
context hook
and here we'll say const context
equals
what is it use context
and we give our auth context
and we do the same thing right here we
can destructure as well here we'll say
from result we get data and from data we
get register
and
register and we will call this or
actually no i made a mistake from data
yeah we open curly braces and we get
register
register and then we give it an alias
and we call it user data
so here we'll say context dot
the same login even though this is a
register but we don't need to have two
functions for
something that does the same so we'll
say context.login because when
registering we're logging in users
so we'll say context.login user data
simple as that
all right so now once we log in or
register our entire application will
have this data inside of the context so
let's save everything
and let's go to our app
to remove that let it reload so now if
we
log in say
user actually can i see the context all
right so let's go to the react dev tools
let's open this
we see that we have a context provider
right here and it has actually this is
the apollo provider so we need to have
the context provider of the auth
provider which has a value here so as we
see we have a value result
user rather of null and a login and a
logout function so if we log in
successfully here one two three
let's actually put seven we log in there
we go we got our user and we get our
user's name is um
actually get a type name because it's
kind of um that's strange that looks
like a graphql kind of
actually graphql has this type name so
ignore myself so we get created that
email an id and the token and the
username
so we have this user in our context but
of course we're not using that in our
application to change the behavior of
our application because for example we
want to change this to
have our username here and we want to
have a logout button here so that we can
use it to log up all right so let's go
here we can close this we no longer need
the app
so let's go to our
menu bar so menu bar
and here we need to get our context
because we want to show a different menu
bar depending on whether we're logged in
or not so it will say import
auth context
oops
these typos
from
i go back to context slash auth
and here at the top again actually i've
got the use context as well this context
and here at the top we'll say const
or actually we can destructure from it
the user and the logout so that we don't
have to type context dot
here we'll say use context and we pass
it our auth context
and um in case you're wondering by the
way just quickly i wanted to explain
here i didn't want to destructure the
log out uh the login rather and just use
login here because it's kind of
confusing there's too many login words
in this component so if by having here
context.login
if someone reads this code and says
context.login it's obvious that this
context is a login from the context so
it's more readable right i can have it
like this like by destructuring it and
just having it like this by super
confusing so i prefer to leave the uh
the context right there just uh
just as a heads up all right so what i
want to do here is that so let's cut all
of this this is the menu that we want to
show when we're not logged in all right
i'm going to create a variable i'll call
it menu bar
because the menu bar is going to be
dynamic so we'll say const menu bar
equals and we'll say user so if user if
we're logged in then we want to show
something
else we want to show this menu that we
had this is what we show when we're not
logged in but when we're logged in let's
actually paste the same menu but we'll
change a couple of things so it's the
same menu but here instead of home we'll
have a button with the username so we'll
say user dot username will have uh their
name there instead of the home and i
want it to always be active so i'll just
remove that condition
and it's not gonna have an on click
but it's going to be a link to the home
right so
here
see here as well on the right let's
remove one and keep one and this will be
the log out
and this will not will never be active
because once you log out the buttons
will change so it will not have an on
click as well or will it actually it
will
its on click will be the log out so here
we'll say log out because once you click
it we want to trigger the context logout
function and it will not go anywhere
so we can remove this as link and to
slash login all right let's save that
and let's see if that works
so we get our context
and we look here and we see that oh yeah
of course we need to log in again let's
say a user and we log in
and we log in cool so our navbar changed
and now we have user i mean it says user
because this user is actually user if i
would log in as
i see it worked i wanted to test it and
i clicked log out all right so the
logout work worked because our user is
null and if i want to log in as another
user like jane now this says jane and
now i have the user jane in my context
and if i click log out that's removed
okay but there's now one problem because
right now if i
log in
and if i just refresh the page we're
back to zero we're not logged in again
we need some way to persist this we can
simply do this by just storing this
token locally on our on this device that
we're using and then once the app loads
we try to fetch a token if this token is
there then we set ourselves to logged in
else we set ourselves to be uh not
logged out i mean the app does it not
we're not doing anything as a user all
right so in the auth right here
we need to persist the uh the token in
the local storage once we log in or log
out so here once we log in so
we'll say local
storage dot set
item
and we can call this token
let's call it jwt token
and the data will be inside of this user
data so we'll say userdata.token
and uh yeah that's it
well actually here in the logout we need
to remove it so here we'll say
log local storage dot remove
item and the name is jwt token
okay now we have this token but we're
not we're not actually checking if we
have it once we start the app so let's
go up here
here we can say if
local storage dot
get item
and it's the jwt token item if this is
truthy that means this item exists um
actually i want to do an extra step here
what i want to do because this token
stores an expiration date and time right
and
i don't want to set our app to be logged
in if this one hour long token has
expired so i need to check whether it's
expired or not but this expiration is
actually encoded inside of the token so
we need to decode it for this we'll um
install a library called jwt decode so
we'll say npm install
jwt
dash decode
all right let's let that install we can
import that we'll say import
let's call it jwt the code like this
from
jwt dash decode
all right now we can use this to decode
our token so we'll say now that we've
got the token actually we can put it in
a variable so we'll say const
token
equals
we can just decode it here actually so
we'll say jwt decode
and we'll call we'll we'll pass it this
this token right here
so we'll pass it actually makes more
sense to call it decoded token here
decoded token
okay so now that we have our decoded
token we can say if
decoded token oops what is that decoded
token
dot exp because this is where that
expiration time is stored and this is
stored in
in like a
what do you call like time from epoch uh
date string and we need to times it by a
thousand because this is like in seconds
we need in milliseconds if this is
smaller than or lesser than date dot now
that means it's actually expired so what
we need to do is we need to delete it
and we set ourselves to not be logged in
so we need to say local storage
dot remove
item we need to remove it because it's
actually expired
we need uh not token jwt
token like this
else if it's not expired we want to set
our user to this decoded token data
because it's it's a valid token and
we're actually logged in
uh
but how do we do oh actually no i made a
mistake here we don't just pass this
initial state like this we can create a
variable initial
state i mean it's not a mistake but we
need to have this as a dynamic value
okay let's copy that and here at the top
we'll have our const
initial state as an object with a user
that's null initially but once we do
this check if the token is expired we
remove it and we leave that initial
state with a null user with a user
that's not but if you if we're not we
need to set this user and then so once
we get here we actually set our user to
this user so we don't set it to no so
here we'll say initial
initial state dot user i still
misspelled it did i misspell that
initial state no that's fine all right
user equals decoded
no again
token
like that uh these misspells are getting
out of hand guys
all right so that should do the trick so
let's save
and let's go to our app make sure
actually we don't get any errors
we don't let's go to our app
so let's go to our console or not
console actually application
and here in local storage
whoa what is all of this
i'm just going to delete everything it's
firebase stuff
all right so here let's log in
as user
136.
there we go we get a jwt token and if we
log out it deletes it all right but now
we need to make sure that it's actually
fetching this data once we um re reload
so now that we have this in our storage
let's actually
refresh the page there we go if we
refresh the page it's actually getting
this data and
giving it to our context because again
if i check in the react dev tools and
open this app open the auth provider and
the provider of it
the context we'll see here
if we expand this value we'll see that
the user is set to our current user and
you see that xp is here and that
i don't know what that is is there it's
probably something that has to do with
some time to live thing
looks like to be the same i don't know
whatever all right so
yeah so that's that for managing um our
user state uh we will use this in the
well actually i forgot to do something i
forgot to handle some edge case because
if we now still go to register
that page is still accessible now of
course that's not good behavior because
we're logged in we wanna we don't wanna
see we don't want to be able to access
the login and the register pages all
right let's fix that
so let's go to our app
for we can do this or actually let's uh
make this into its own component because
uh we'll make the app uh component
massive otherwise or the uh the app file
so here in the util i'll create what am
i doing i'll close everything i'll
create a uh
a thing called auth route
so this is essentially going to be the
opposite of a protected route component
what this will do is that
instead of these two login and register
routes we'll have an auth route that
checks if we're logged in and we try to
go to slash login or stash register it's
actually going to redirect us to the to
the um
to the actual home page because we don't
need to go to those pages if we're
logged in
so here of course we need react
and we need use context because we need
to access our context our auth context
from react
and here we need to import
route and uh what is redirect yeah
redirect redirect
from react
router
dom
and here we'll say const
call this auth
route
or we can have it as a function function
uh auth route and this will take um
this will take some props and inside
these props we'll have a component so
we'll pass down our actual route
component but let's give this an alias
of component with a capital
c so that we can use it as a component i
know that's confusing but
hopefully you'll understand when you see
what i'm gonna type later
so here we need to get our user
so we say const
um or actually i need to get to the
context so here let's say import let's
make space between them and say auth
context
context
from
go back one level to context slash auth
and here we can destructure our user
from use context
and auth context so now that we have our
user we can check so we'll say return
let's return
we return a route
and inside of this route we'll spread
whatever we got passed from um from the
uh from the thing that wraps this
and then we will do a render prop uh
expression here we'll say render and
we'll open the curly braces and we'll
say
props
and we'll um
do an arrow and then we will check for
the user here so oops what is this
all right so here i'll say i'll tap this
in and we'll say user and then do a
ternary operator so if we have the user
then we just return a redirect redirect
to um
to slash like this
and then
else we will just return that component
that we got passed down
component and we will give it these
our props that we we have received so
props and then we close it like this now
of course we need to export this
actually i need to close this route so
like that
and here we'll say export
default
auth oops auth route
all right let's save that let's go back
to our app and here we'll import that
we'll say import
auth route
from
uh the same level util slash auth route
and here instead of doing that
we'll just say auth
route
and here as well we'll say auth route
and pass the same stuff so what this
essentially does is uh we'll do an
author out which is this component right
here and we'll pass all these attributes
right here the exact the path and the
component and once we get here and we
get our user
if we have this user inside of this
route we will render oops inside of this
wrap we'll actually return it as a
redirect which will just if we click it
it will just i mean if we trigger it it
will just redirect to slash but if we
don't have a user we're just going to
put that component that we have uh with
these props that we just passed down
here
i hope that makes sense
all right so let's look at our app
so now that we're logged in if we go to
our
uh to our login page to log in
now we get redirected immediately to the
home page and if we go to
register as well we get redirected all
right so this is it for this class in
the next class we will actually start to
work on posting data and we will add the
post form here and we will be able to
add some more posts as this user that
we're logged in
so now that we've set up our auth
context for our application to know
whether we're logged in or not now we
can use that the information to
decide on whether to show something or
not one example of this is we're gonna
now uh add a post form for us to be able
to submit a post as a user from the home
page so let's get to that all right
let's go to our app make sure you have
your server and client running uh i do
on mine so i'm just going to close this
terminal window
let's go to the home page
so home and here right here at the top i
want to show another column if we're
logged in and put that post form in that
column so here um before this loading
tag here we'll say
grid actually no we need to get the user
from the context first here i'll say
actually here we'll say we'll import the
context so import
auth context
from
go back to
context slash auth
so here we'll actually need to use
we need to get the use context hook as
well
so here we'll say const we can
destructure the user
equals
use context and we'll pass it our auth
context
like that
now now that we have the user so here
we'll say if user
we will render this markup actually not
percentage we'll do and and like this so
if we have a user that means if we're
logged in let's show this form so here
we'll say uh what is it grid
dot column that we want to show
and let's close that and inside of here
we'll put our form but i want to put
this in its own component because
otherwise this will be massive and we'll
have another mutation written as well
here on top of this query that we have
so here i'll simply say post form and
close this tag
of course we haven't created it yet but
we will so here we'll say import post
post form from so here we're in pages so
we have to go back one level and go to
component slash post form
all right let's uh
close this let's go to our components
and create a file called post form so js
and let's say rcf and tab
doesn't work
oh it's rfc
anyway it refuses to work for some
reason let's type it manually
these snippets sometimes are weird maybe
it's interacting with another extension
all right so here we'll say function
post form
oops
and it's going to do something and we
need to export it as well so export
default
post form
all right let me close that
so here what we need to do is we need to
actually import the uh
the form from semantic ui so it's a
import form
from semantic ui react
and we need our custom use form hook as
well so here we'll say import use form
from go back one level to util slash
hooks
so all right let's go to our component
here we'll say return
and let's open our form
this will have a on submit of on submit
on submit
and let's close that and inside of here
we're going to have uh actually let's
put a header first let's put a header
too saying create a post colon and here
we'll have only one field
but i'm going to have it as a field
because i want the button to be inside
of it contained in it so here we'll say
form
dot field
and close this and inside of here we'll
have the form
dot input
element and this will have a couple of
props so we will have a place
holder
holder will say
hi world like the name of the app
and
we'll have a name
let's call this body because this is the
body of the post we have the non change
of
on change
we'll get this from the use form hook so
he'll have a value which is going to be
values.body oops
dot
body
and
we'll have as well an error
which we will handle later or actually
we'll we'll handle the error later for
now let's just have it like this
and let's put a button a submit button
so it will be of type
submit
and let's give it a teal color so color
teal
let's close that and it will say submit
and here let's bring the button as well
from semantic ui
all right so now we need to use our use
form and create these values and
unchange and whatnot so you will say
const values
and on change
and on submit
submit
as you're used to the custom hook we'll
say use form and we'll have a callback
let's call it create post callback
and we'll have an initial state which
will just have a body of
that's an empty string all right now we
need to actually write our mutation to
persist a post to our database so here
let's write the mutation so here we'll
say const what do we call it create
create post mutation
and we need to bring gql so let's say
import
gql from graphql
tag
graphql
so here we'll say
gql
open the template string and we'll say
mutation oops
all right let me type that down
we'll say mutation
let's call this create post
and this will take a body
of type string and that's required and
inside of here it will call the create
post mutation that we created and it
will pass it a body of the value body
like that
so let's actually get everything that we
get back so the id
the body the created add
the username
we've got the likes with everything
inside of them so we get the id of the
like the username
and the created ad
and we'll get the like count
we'll get the comments
and from comments we're gonna get the id
the body
uh the username and the created at
same stuff that we get from uh fetch all
posts and here we'll get the comment
count as well
and yeah that's everything
all right so now we need to use this
mutation so here uh okay we need the
used mutation hook so here we'll say
import
use mutation
from
uh at apollo slash react hooks
and here we'll say
const uh create post and uh
we'll get actually the way we handled
errors on the register and login page
was that and we did we used the on error
method and then we set them to local
errors but here it doesn't make sense
because we only have one error and we
don't want we're not going to extra
extract it from a deeply nested property
so i'm just going to get it like this
i'm just going to get it from the
um this second parameter so we will say
error like that and we'll say use
mutation
and we'll pass it our create post
mutation and we'll pass it our variables
which will be the values which only
holds the body
so we'll have an update
and
or have i been used i think i've been
using the function form so i'll stick to
that so update and we'll emit the proxy
and we'll have the
result and here we'll say
um we're just going to console.log the
result
for now
and
we need to reset actually the the body
field because we want to empty the the
body field once we submit it
all right this should be uh fine we
shouldn't have any errors so let's save
and let's look at our app cool we don't
have any errors
all right let's look at our app
okay we get an error now because
create post callback yeah it's not
defined and on change i'm gonna
misspelled something here
uh yeah on change like that and we need
this callback so this callback needs to
be here
and it will only call the
create
post
like that actually i forgot to add the
function keyword function
like that
all right let's save
okay so let's open our developer tools
and uh
let's login
we log in okay now that we have a token
but now if i submit a post of course
it's going to fail because it's going to
ask me authorization header must be
provided now we need to set up our
apollo client in a way that once we have
a
token in our storage we need to get that
token get it and add it as an
authorization header automatically
without having to add it each time we
send the request we can do this by using
something called uh apollo
an apollo link context
link context
and let's go to the apollo graphql
website
and so yeah this actually no it's not
this page i was looking for a different
page apollo link context okay so yeah
we'll use this uh set context uh
function from apollo link context and
the way this works is uh it kind of
works like a middleware so it sets a
context of this request and kind of
modifies whatever you want to like do
before that request is pros um kind of
forwarded towards the http link so let's
install this and actually set it up so
i'm going to open a new window and say
npm install actually let's cd into the
client first
and i'll say npm install apollo
link context like that
so we need to set it up in our
apollo provider so let's go to our
apollo provider
and here let's import that so we'll
import the set context function set
context
from apollo
link
context
and here we'll
create this new link and we'll say uh
const
auth link equals set context
and this will have a handler this takes
a request and a previous context that we
can kind of get data from and edit and
forward uh to the next operation but we
don't need any of these parameters
so we can just emit them and just do
like this
just an empty
empty argument list and here we need to
get our token from the local storage so
we'll say cons token equals local
storage dot get item
and remember we named the jwt token
so now that we have it we need to set it
as a as a authorization header so here
we'll say return because this will
modify the um
modify the current request so here we'll
say return and we'll do an object and
inside of that there's another object
and we have a or actually no that's
going to be inside of the header so
we'll join object and inside of that we
have a headers and we'll add an
authorization header so author
authorization
and we need to check if we have the
token because we might not have it so
we'll say token and we'll do a ternary
operator so if it's the case if it's uh
if we have a token want to say bearer
and do like a template string so we can
add a variable here and then let's put
the uh token here
else we'll just uh add an authorization
header with an empty string uh value now
this will kind of merge the existing
headers of the request with this uh
headers object that we gave so it will
just add this authorization header all
right of course now we're not using this
yet so let's use that or actually let me
put this on top of the
client declaration here because we need
to use it here
and here we just need to
add concatenate it to this link but it
needs to go before the http link so we
can say auth link dot we'll use the
javascript concat function and say
concat and pass this
our http link all right this should
actually add the token to our request
and
successfully send any protected
api calls all right let's save this
and let's go to our app
let's make sure we have a token all
right we do we have a token and it's uh
it's valid i logged in less than an hour
ago so now if we say let's go to our
network clear everything out and we just
send some gibberish we press enter
we get a request here
all right it says args is not defined
let me check the server code
okay i added this line for validation
last time but instead of saying just
body i actually added this args object
so let me save that and run the server
again and test
all right let's test it
click submit
and there we go we get a 200 response
and we get create opt create post and it
actually you know returns us the post
that's been created so it's successfully
been created now of course it's not
showing on the front end because we
hadn't added any code to uh to do that
all right so if we refresh and we fetch
the post again there we go that's our
post right there
now the way we're going to show this
post on the front end is we're not going
to use context we're going to use apollo
cache in memory but the problem with
that is if we look at the apollo dev
tools if we go to cache
you'll see by the way in the polar dev
tools you can see right here the queries
the queries that we're sending so once
the app loaded it just sent this get
posts query to get all the posts and if
we go to cache there are a couple of
things here but if you go to root query
you'll see that all the queries that we
sent
we send are actually stored separately
so the get post query right now is
caching five posts we need a way to
directly access this cache and modify
and add this new post that we just added
and we can do this
uh i hope this time
the google search works so let's go to
yeah caching data
let's go a bit down
it's right here yeah direct cache access
so what we need to do we're going to
access the cache directly and we're
going to use
now here they're using render props and
they're using the client variable or
object but we don't have access to that
but instead we have access to the pro
the proxy object which will let us
perform this is a bit confusing but you
will understand it the more you use it
we actually gonna gonna perform
graphql queries on our existing client
data instead of actually reaching to the
server all right let's actually apply
this
so let's go to our
post form
and here on the update instead of just
log in the result we want to access this
cache so here actually we're not going
to omit the proxy we're going to write
proxy like that and we're going to say
proxy
dot
read
read
query
and we need to pass a query here and
this query will be let's say if you had
the po get posts query and you sent it
here it will actually fetch the post
from the client data that's stored in
the cache but the problem here we're
already using this query in the home
page we want we don't want to type it
again so what we can do we can outsource
it to its own file so let's copy this
entire query from the home page let's
copy let's cut it actually
and in the util folder let's create a
file called graphql.js
and here we'll say
we'll export it we'll export const
fetch post query like that and of course
we need gql so here we'll say import gql
from
graph
ql tag now in the home we need to import
it and use it so here we'll say
import
fetch
posts query
from we go back one level to util slash
graphql now we don't need gql anymore so
in the home it's going to work the same
the same way it did before and in the
post form now we need to get that
fetch
fetch posts uh query so we'll say fetch
posts
query
query
from we go back uh one level to util
slash graph ql
all right so now in read query we just
pass this fetch posts query
like actually but we need to give it uh
to put it in a query variable and we
just pass it like that
now
let's put this in a variable so we'll
say const data equals proxy dot read
query and we pass that query now all
that data that's in our cache is sitting
inside of this data variable so but it's
inside of an another variable called get
post because remember this is this data
that we're getting is the root query
it's this data right here so our posts
are inside of get posts
so here we need to edit that get posts
entry so we'll say data dot get posts
equals now that we have the result here
we can just say open a an array and we
want to put it at the top because this
is the newest post so we'll say result
dot data dot get post because this is
where our response is stored and then
comma and then we'll spread the existing
get post
so we'll spread the existing posts now
of course we need to persist this so for
this we'll use proxy.writequery
and here we'll say the query is
fetch
post query and the data will be just
this data object right here all right
let's save everything
actually let's save all files make sure
you save all files now let's go to our
app
okay so it says graphql
cannot resolve graphql
i misspelled the name of the file here
graph
graph ql
let's save
let's refresh
no such okay i misspelled it somewhere
else probably in the home
okay that's uh renamed
and here as well it's renamed okay
third time is the charm all right cool
so now if we go to our cache we see that
we have five posts and if we post a new
one
all right it breaks
so it can't cannot read property id of
undefined
okay because i made a mistake here the
data is actually stored in create post
not get post
because that's the name of the mutation
all right so let's save this should work
now
it did send that mutation but it didn't
persist it properly in the cache because
i misspelled the i made the gave the
wrong mutation name so now if i post one
and if we look at the cache so look at
the root query we have six posts so if
we submit this now it's seven posts and
it actually shows so if we say another
one
it's actually shown on our front end all
right that's cool one thing that i
wanted to show you is that here when you
look at the queries if we go to this
post and we go back it sends another
query called um get posts
but i've set up our server code in a way
that each time we send a request from
each of the resolvers let's say the
create post resolvers is gonna
console.log create posts and the other
the get posts will console.log that and
the getpost will console.log that just
for us to see when the these actual
resolvers are being hit so here you see
we get posts once but in our app in our
front end if we go back and if we go
back to the home page it sends that
query but from our server it doesn't
print that again because it's actually
sending that query to the client side um
cache not to the server side the first
one is the only one that's actually
being sent to the server but the other
two are actually sent to the client side
cache just for you to bear in mind if
you see this list of queries and you're
thinking this is actually sending too
many requests to our servers it's not
it's just sending that one first request
hello my dear class it's nice to have
you here
welcome to class number seven where we
write some more code
all right actually one thing that i
forgot to uh to do last time is to show
the validation error if we actually
submit an empty post because if we click
submit if we open our console we see
that we get an error but we're not
showing it to the user so let's fix that
let's go to our app let's go to the make
sure you have your server running
let's go to the post form
so here
we've already extracted the error object
so we just need to go under the form
here and we check for it so we'll say um
error
and end and that means if we have this
error then let's show a div with the
class of ui so dot ui dot error
dot message
let's tab
this has given us an error because we
can't put two uh sibling com
elements under one component so we can
just do this which is shorthand for
fragment and we can just put that code
back in and now we can say we can put a
ul with a class of list
and put our errors and we only have one
so we don't need to loop through
anything we just put in an ally and
inside of that we'll put error dot graph
ql errors and we get the first one
dot message like that and that should
take care of it
uh one more thing actually here inside
of the input we want to
use the error boolean to invalidate the
input itself and make it red so here
we'll check for error we'll do a ternary
so if error is truthy then uh the error
is true else it's false all right let's
save
and make sure we have no errors and i've
said error like a bazillion times all
right let's check now if i don't type
anything and i press enter there we go
again post body must not be empty now
let's give this some margin because that
looks uh
that looks weird
all right so here let's go let's give
this a style just an inline style and
we'll say
put another object we'll say
margin
bottom
oops bottom
uh let's give it 20. let's save let's
look at that
even if you put spaces by the way it
will still be not valid all right cool
that looks better
okay so actually one other thing that i
wanted to add is the transition group
because right now if we just post
something it just kind of snaps in which
doesn't look that good uh semantic ui
makes it really easy to use these like
really cool like transitions if you look
at this leaf how it shows how it leaves
and we can control
uh no pun intended with the leave and
leave we can control as well like the
duration of the transition we're just
going to use this group transition thing
which is pretty cool
if we look you just get transition from
semantic ui and you wrap everything in a
transition group here they're using a
divider and size and everything but
we'll just use the duration so let's go
to our
actually you know in the home so home
and here we'll get transition from a
semantic ui transition
so right here where we loop through all
of our uh posts we need to wrap all of
this inside of a transition group so
let's cut to this and then here we'll
say transition
position
dot group
and here we'll actually we need to put
it in curly braces and we'll paste it
back so let's save that
let's look at it so if we add another
one
there you go it doesn't just snap in it
just shows kind of like it fades in and
later when we delete them as well they
fade out and then it kind of moves back
all right so in this class we're going
to work on these buttons make them
actually functional and add like a
delete button
by the way just as a reminder if you
haven't subscribed please subscribe to
the channel and hit the bell button so
that i will annoy you with every video
that i drop i usually post three a week
so i'm not going to be that annoying
okay
all right so let's actually jump into
the code all right before we work on the
like button i just want to um make this
comment button it's gonna have simple
functionality which is when we click on
it it's just going to take us to the
page of that
of that post and i want to add the
delete button on this side as well if
it's our post so that we can delete it
all right so let's go here
let's go to the postcard
so right here this um right here this is
the comment uh button we're just gonna
wrap the whole thing in a link
or can we make the button itself as a
link actually let's try that so let's
remove the on click and here we'll say
as
uh link
and we'll say two equals slash actually
this is dynamic value dynamic value so
we'll do backticks we'll do a slash
posts slash
the id because we already have access
from
to the id from the props
all right let's see if that works do we
have link imported yeah we do okay let's
look at our app
all right cool it works so if we click
on that it takes us to the id of that
post
okay let's add the delete button
i'm not going to add functionality but
i'm just going to add the dummy button
for now
for us to have the delete button we need
to access the user because of course we
need to
if we have to be logged in and we have
to have this post as our post for us to
be able to see a delete button on it so
here we'll get the we'll import the alt
context so we'll say import auth context
from we go back one level to context
slash auth and we need the use context
hook so let's say here
use
context
context like that
and here at the top we'll say const will
extract our user or destructure our user
from use context
auth
context
so right here we don't need this comment
on post anymore
and here at the bottom
right
actually yeah here after the uh the like
button we'll do a an expression and
we'll check for the user so if we have a
user so we're logged in and
user.username
equals
username so what this means the username
of the user that we're logged in as if
it's equal to the username of this post
that means this is the owner so we need
to show a delete button on this postcard
so we'll say and end like this that
means if all of this is true then we'll
show the following and the following is
a button so button
um as div
and we'll give it a color of red because
the delete button and we'll give it an
on click for now this is just gonna
like um we'll just have like a callback
and it will console.log delete post like
that
and we'll put a an icon inside of here
so icon
and the name of the icon is trash which
is going to give us a um a kind of a
trash bin icon
all right let's see if that okay so it
vs code auto imported those things for
me which is pretty cool so let's save
let's look at our app
so there we go so user all the posts by
user which is the user that we're logged
in as have this delete button in them
but this delete button looks a bit weird
let's
inspect it
okay for some reason this uh
ui button inside has some margin some
like negative margin on the side yeah
negative three let's uh just override
that so this icon we can just say style
equals
uh oops put an object here and we'll
just say margin 0.
let's see if that fixes it
all right cool
we can give
this button a floated property so this
button right here will say floated
and let's give it the floater to the
right so it floats to the right
all right cool it looks much better now
it's floated to the right and we can
click it and if you click it it's just
going to say delete post of course we'll
add functionality later
all right so the like button what i want
to do with it i want to make it into its
own component so that we can have like
leaner components like i said more
modularity plus we're going to need this
button on the single post page as well
so that will we don't re repeat code
across components so
this is the like button
uh no not this actually it's this let's
copy let's cut the whole thing
and here we'll put a like button
component like that oops
like that
and
so here we'll import that so we'll
import import
like
like button
from i'm gonna put this in
where are we in components
yeah we're in components so so from the
same directory
like button
now this like button is going to need to
access some things because this like
button needs to know uh the use um not
the username it needs to know the number
of likes so that it shows it and he
needs to know the likes of this post so
it determines whether this user has
liked this post or not and it needs to
know the idea of the post itself so that
it would look in those post we can pass
it the
entire post but that's not necessary
well we can pass it a new object
uh with just the id
the likes and what else uh yeah the like
count the like count like that
all right let's save and let's create
this new component so here we'll say new
file
like uh button
dot js
we'll get a couple of things so react
and
use state oops not parentheses black
curly brackets
or braces so let me get use state
uh from react
uh we'll need link
because we could be not logged in and we
want to go to the home page if we click
this
or the login page rather from react
oops router
dom
we'll need
the use mutation hook from react from
apollo
from
apollo react hooks
and we'll need gql as well to write our
graphql query
or mutation from graphql tag
okay so we'll say function
like
button
it's gonna take the props that we had so
from that we'll destructure from the
post
we're gonna get the id
the like count
count and the likes
all right
so here at the bottom we'll say export
default
like
button
okay we need to access the user here
actually we can just pass it here i mean
we can access it with the with with
importing the context but it will be
kind of easier to just prop drill it
will say user equals
the user
and inside of here using that user
object we're going to determine whether
we've liked this or not because we've if
we've already liked this post we want to
show the button okay our app is broken
but we want to show the button like kind
of filled with green otherwise you want
to show it like outlined and as well if
we're not logged in we want to show it
outlined and if we click on it it takes
us to the login page
so here we need to determine whether
we've liked it or not so first thing we
use use effect so
actually we need to import use effect so
we say use
effect and
our callback
so callback like this
will uh check
so here we'll say if user
so of course we have to check if we have
a user first if we're logged in
and now that we have the likes we can
check and user dot find and let's find a
like
where the like dot username
equals
the user dot
username
so here we'll say like that
which means if any of the likes on this
post have a username of this user that
means this user that we're logged in in
or logged in as has liked this post so
we'll say oh actually we need a liked
boolean as well so here we'll say const
liked
and set
liked
equals use state
let's just give it a default value of
false
and here if this is true that means
it's like so we'll say set liked
to true
else
set liked
to false
and
here we'll give it a dependency array of
the user
and the likes themselves if any of these
change recalculate the value
here we need to return our button
so
so what we copied from earlier we put it
here and
i think we're going to change actually
we're not going to change much here this
will be a dynamic value because we don't
want to either fill it or not we want we
need to determine whether we've liked
this post or not so here we'll say
we cut that we'll say const like
button
button like this equals
and uh actually we're gonna put it here
so let's just put it now like button
now here we need to check for the user
so i'll write this and i'll explain it
right we'll do a ternary operator and
then parentheses so if user and now if
liked so another ternary operator and
here we'll paste that back in but here
instead of basic we're gonna have the
filled button because we've liked it so
it's gonna be filled so else if we've
not liked it let's paste that back in
and it's gonna be that it's gonna be the
outline button
now here outside of this parenthesis we
do another colon so else if we if we
don't have a user that means we're not
logged in so we'll have the same button
and it's going to have basic because
it's going to be outlined but this
should be a link to the login page so
here we'll say as
link
did we import link yes so as link to
um this is going to be to slash or
actually just like that slash
login
all right i think that should take care
of it
uh now one thing of course we need to
have an on click this like post we need
to have the mutation so let's write the
mutation down here
here we'll say const
like
post
mutation
equals
gql gql
[Music]
oh i misspelled that
okay gql mutation
like post
is going to take a post id
our server code and it's going to be of
type id and that's that's required and
it's going to trigger the po like post
mutation
and we'll pass this a post id of dollar
sign post id
and we'll get a couple of things and
i'll explain later why we got those
things and hopefully this time i won't
forget to explain because i did this
thing last time where i said i'll
explain later i forgot to explain that
thing
all right if i do that by the way you
can drop a comment and tell me oh you
forgot to explain that and i'll explain
it to you in a comment
okay so i'll leave that like that and
now we need to use use mutation to get
that function so here we'll say const
like post
here we'll get the error actually we're
not gonna have any errors
so here we'll say use mutation
we might have an error but the error
would have to be that our token is
expired or something and that has
nothing to do with the like post so
we'll just get the like post function
so here we'll say use mutation of course
we'll pass it our like post mutation and
we'll have some variables
and the variables will be uh the post id
and that's going to be the id that we
have from here from our props
all right that should take care of that
and that's named the same as this one so
that should be fine
uh everything here should be fine
actually let's save all files
let's look at our console okay there's a
couple of problems here
we need to get button and label
from semantic ui
so let's say actually up here we'll say
import
button
label
and icon
[Music]
from symantec ui react let's save
user is not defined oh yeah we need to
actually get the user as well from our
props
uh like post is defined but not be used
in postcard yeah okay
postcard oh yeah okay so this is useless
now let's remove that
and let's save
no duplicate props allowed in postcard
line 30.
okay so we're passing
we're passing the user oh no hi here
okay this should be as the link let's
remove the div
all right
okay cool so
oh that's working all right so this one
that we've liked is actually filled this
one that we haven't liked is empty and
if we click
there we go it likes and it actually
increments it and if you notice if we go
to our apollo cache
you'll see that it's actually updating
okay let's make this a bit bigger
cache root query so let's look at the
first one right it has zero likes but if
i like it now it's actually updating it
now you might be wondering how is it
updating the cache without us having to
say proxy.right query or something like
that but the way that's happening is
because
let's close that if we look at our
mutation
we're specifying the id of the post that
we're getting back so we're getting back
a resource of type post and apollo is
smart enough to realize okay we're
getting a resource of type post and it's
got this id that means let's update our
uh the post that we have with this id
with any of these fields these new
fields that we've received so it does it
automatically we don't have to do
anything which is pretty amazing
actually so we didn't have to write any
code to change our client-side state
one thing that i don't like right now is
that if we like a post it kind of stays
focused focused when we have to click
away for the color to change
so let's inspect this
and
this the ui button
okay so the button has this color so
let's copy this this is the normal color
so if we focus it becomes this dark
color
okay so it's this rule right right here
let's copy this rule
all of that
okay
[Music]
okay let's go to our app css
and here let's paste that
and we'll say background color
background
color
and let's take that color again from
here it's got that
let's paste it here let's save
everything
all right so now even if it's focused
it's going to be that bright color and
not the darker color
all right so that's working
and so that's i think that's it for this
video yeah that's it
hello class
so instead of going to sleep on time
tonight i decided to record this video
sleep is for the week hey let's hope i
don't regret this decision in the
morning
all right so welcome to class number
eight
i think it's number eight
yeah all right so last in the last class
we did these buttons and we uh added
functionality for the like button but
right now we're going to work on the
single post page because right now if we
go to it it's just empty
so
um the way we're going to approach this
we're going to we're going to get this
id from the url and then use the get
post get singular post mutation or
rather query and then fetch that post
and display it in this page so let's get
to that okay first thing is let's create
a route for that
by the way make sure your server and
your client are running as per usual
let's go to the app.js
and here at the bottom of the container
we're going to add another route so
route
and we'll have exact path
will be slash
posts slash
colon post id
like that and the component
will be a new page called let's call it
single
post
let's import that up here
so import
single post oops
from
pages slash single
post okay let's create that so here in
pages i'm going to create
excuse me singlepost.js
and here the usual will get react
from react
and we'll say function
what's wrong with that
import
okay there's some ts thing
for some reason
but let's let's ignore that for now
let's say single post
i'm gonna need the props and i'll tell
you why later
here let's uh export default
single post
so here first thing we need to get the
post id from the url so we'll say const
post id equals and we'll get this from
props dot actually this is one other
reason why we need props
dot match dot params so the url
parameters and we call this post id so
we'll get that
and let's write the mutation right now
or the query rather
so here we'll say const
we'll call this fetch
post
query
this will be gql
this would be a good time to import gql
as well so here we'll say import gql
actually gql from
graph ql
oops graphql tag
and here we'll say
query
and this needs to take a post id
of type id and that's required
and this will run the get post query and
we'll take a post id
that's actually our post id
and here let's get everything so id body
created add
username
and get like count
i'm gonna get likes and from that we'll
get uh just the username
and we'll get a comment account
we'll get the comments and get from the
comments we'll get the id the username
uh the created ad
and the body
yeah that's it let's uh save so that
formats
and here let's start to create our
markup and then
and then see what we need so this will
be conditional so we'll say let
because this depends on whether we're
logged in or not so we'll say post
markup or actually not not logged in
whether we
have the data from the query or not yet
so we'll say if
um actually
let me get the get post so
we'll get the use query hook so we'll
say import use
query from
at apollo react hooks
and here we'll say const
and we'll get
data and straight away from that we'll
get the get post
field and here we'll say equals use
query
and we'll pass it the oops fetch
post query
and this needs some variables
and the variables will be
will be our
actually we'll do an object and we'll
say post id like this meaning it's going
to be post id and the value will be this
post id right here
um
we can here do a console log of post id
to make sure that we're getting our post
id just in case
and here so here we'll say if not get
post because we might be still loading
we'll say post
markup
equals
and here we'll just put a paragraph and
say loading post
uh feel free to put a spinner here but
i'm just gonna leave it as a um
as a paragraph for now and we'll say
else so else if we have the post
uh we need to get all the fields from
the post so we'll say const and we'll
use destructuring and we'll say id
body
created
at
get username
what else comments
get likes
uh like count
and comment count
say equals uh what is it uh from
yeah from get post
let's make this wrap so press alt z okay
so now we can say post markup
equals
and we'll use the grid
and inside of here of course we will
need to import these in a bit but let's
uh
do a row here
and uh right here i want to have the um
an image but of course this is hard
coded so it's the same like in the
postcard component so i'm going to grab
this source attribute so i'll just copy
that
and we'll come back here we'll say
so this will be inside of the image tag
oops image like that
and let's paste that source attribute
and i'm going to give this a size of
small
and let's make this float to the right
so we'll say float
oops float equals
right
and we can close it like that
actually this needs to be in a column so
i'll cut that and say grid
red dot
column
and let's actually give this a
width of
two
and here we'll put our image back
and now we're gonna have the rest so the
rest will be a grid with a width of 10
because that's the
the number of remaining spaces let's
remove this image and
here we'll have our card so let's put
card
let's give it the property fluid so it
takes up all the width and here we'll
have as per usual card dot content
here we'll have a header so card
dot header
this will be the user name so i'll put
uh
an expression and say username or curly
braces but username
we'll get meta which is the
created art so card dot
mata
and oops here we'll say curly braces and
we'll say
actually we need to format it so i will
say we need to import moment a moment
it will say import
moment from
moment
let's go down here we'll say moment
we'll pass it the created at
and say dot from
now
and uh yeah that's fine
here we'll say card
description scription
and here we'll just put the body of the
post
um underneath these uh this card content
let's put a ruler a horizontal ruler to
have a line between them and here i want
to put the like button and the comment
button just like in the card since we
have those in their own component we can
just attach them here so here we'll say
um another card
uh content
this will be the x we'll give this extra
the extra attribute
and here we'll say
like button
we need to import that but let's
actually we need to pass the user to the
like button so
we need to import the um the auth
context
so here we'll say import auth
context
from go back one level to um context
slash auth
and we need to get the use context hook
from react so use
context up here oops con
text
and up here we'll say
const and we can destructure it we'll
say const user like that equals use
context
and we'll pass our auth
context
so here we'll pass our user and it
doesn't matter if we're not logged in
so right here in the like button we're
going to say user equals user
and we'll pass the post like we did in
the postcard but we're just gonna of
course pass the id the like
count
and the likes array so that the button
determines whether we've liked it or not
and uh here let's close that and let's
put the
comment button
which is not going to do anything for
now but we'll make it do in stuff in the
future
let's give it the basic attribute
and
or actually no
let's make it as a div
and here let's say label position
equals
right
so we'll have that um kind of
arrow to the left so let's say on click
equals
for now it's just gonna console.log
console.log
and let's just say comment on post
we'll make this do stuff in the future
but for now we'll just leave it like
that
and inside this button we're gonna have
another button so a button
this is the basic button because this is
the uh kind of cloud thing
uh here we'll say color is blue
oops and inside of the button we're
going to put the icon so it'll say icon
um
the name of the icon did we use comment
or comments
so right here yeah comments so we'll
keep using the same icon so here we'll
say
comments
let's close that
and
underneath this button we need the label
and we need to show the number of
of comments so here we'll say label
basic
and the color is blue
and this label will be pointing
to the left
pointing left like that and inside the
label we're just going to have comment
count
um
here actually we need to show the um the
delete button
uh but we already have that in the
postcard
but actually it's not doing anything
right now i forgot to add functionality
to the delete button because right now
it's not actually deleting the post so
we can take care of that right now so
what we need to do we need to put this
delete button into its own component so
let's go to the
yeah right here so where this button is
we can just cut this
and we'll say if
user and the username of the user is the
same as the username of the person that
posted this
so we'll say here
delete
button
and this delete button is to access the
uh post id so that it would use the
delete post uh or remove post mutation
so here we'll say post id equals
we have this id yeah we have this id and
id we can just say post id equals id
like that
and uh we need to pass it um
actually i don't think we need to pass
it anything here
yeah let's just um close it off and here
let's say import
delete
button from
uh same directory
delete
button because remember this is we're in
the postcard
and here in the components let's create
a delete
button.js file
and here we'll
import
react
and of course we'll import gql
from graph ql tag
and here we'll import the
use mutation hook
from
add apollo react hooks
and uh we're gonna need the
button because that's what we copied
actually let me make sure let me check
what we copied so here i'll say function
delete
uh
yeah that's showing an error because of
this i'll just comment this for a second
delete button
it's going to take the props
and let's just export that for now
export default
delete
button
let's say return
let's put that okay so we need button
and icon so here we'll uncomment that
we'll say button
and icon
from
semantic
ui react
so let's go to the bottom here and let's
write the delete post mutation so we'll
say const
delete post
mutation
equals
gql
open the tag template
and we'll say mutation
delete
post
and this will take a post id
of type id and that's required
and it will just call the delete post
mutation
and pass a post id
of value post id
now we don't need the return um from
this we just need to make sure that it
runs successfully so we can just leave
it like that
and we'll go here and use our used
mutation hook and get the uh
the callback function from that or the
trigger function so we'll say
um const
i'll say delete oops delete post
equals
use
mutation
and we'll pass our
delete post mutation and here we'll need
some
variables so inside of this we'll say
variables
and we'll have post id like that
and we'll have an update here update
i've
we can get a proxy
well i don't think we need the proxy
actually for now
we'll just say update
and um
the way i want to set up this i want to
set it up so we have like a confirm uh
model because we don't want to if a user
by mistake clicks the delete button we
don't want it to immediately click we
want kind of like a model to appear that
says are you sure you want to delete
this post and then when a user then
clicks yes i'm sure then it actually
deletes it
so what i'm gonna do here
we're gonna
get something called confirm from
from symantec ui so get that confirmed
but this this has a boolean like whether
it's open or not so here we'll uh
actually let's get use state as well
so bear with me a moment this will make
sense in a in a second
so here we'll say const
confirm
open
and we'll have set
confirm
open
equals use state and by default it will
be false oops
false
and
let's go down here in the um
in here so underneath the button we're
going to put the confirm so we'll say
confirm
and here we'll have an open um
boolean which will be the confirm
open so confirm open like that and by
the way this is in the documentation if
you want to check check it out and
you'll have a an on cancel
function
and this is when you click so you get
this model and it says
yes or no and this would happen when you
click no so when we click now we just
want to close the uh the confirm model
we don't want to do anything so we'll
just set this confirm open to false so
we'll say set confirm open
and we'll pass it the value false
and we need an unconfirm so on
uh confirm and this is so this is when
we actually uh say yes we are sure we
want to delete the post so we want this
to call the uh the delete post function
from used mutation
and here let's close
our confirm
this is a problem because we have two
sibling
components inside one component
or
rather you know elements so here we can
just wrap everything in a fragment so
that error is gone now
and let's go up here
so here in the update uh once the once
we reach the update that means the post
has been deleted successfully we want to
close the model so we'll say set confirm
open
to false
and of course
this will not disappear from from our
front end because we're not removing it
from the cache but let's do this later
so i'll put a to-do here so i'll put a
comment and say to do
and say uh remove post from cache
so that the change is reflected on the
front end without us having to fetch the
posts again
and um okay so we'll say here oh okay we
need to put a comma here
by the way this is the to do highlight
extension that that highlights the to do
all right so
i think that's fine
or actually here
the post id is not just post id it's
coming from the props so we need to say
uh prop or actually we need to just
destructure it so here we'll say
post id like that
uh i think that's fine so let's save the
delete button
and let's save the postcard but let's
not save the single post and let's go to
the pay uh to the app component uh and
just remove a comment for a second the
route and the import so that we can just
test the um
we can test the postcard alone let's
make sure we don't have any errors okay
so set confirm open is not defined
because i misspelled that
right here that's a capital c save all
right cool it's running let's check it
out
okay so we get syntax error name found
something
let's check our mutation there's a
problem there
mutation delete post
okay here it's just a post id like that
and uh
i'm gonna do it like that here all right
okay so we get this and if we click on
the delete okay nothing happens
it doesn't delete it
okay there's something wrong
okay we want when we click this button
it doesn't just say delete post it
actually sets the model to
to open so we'll say set confirm open to
true
and let's save
okay let's look at our app so now if we
click it sets the model to open if we
click cancel it just closes it and it
doesn't delete it we can just refresh to
make sure it doesn't delete it and if we
click delete now and you click ok
it actually deletes if we open the um if
we do f12 when we go to the network
and uh for some reason
they didn't show up because i didn't
open it previously but if i um refresh
you see that that post was deleted so if
we post a new one and we click here and
we delete it of course it doesn't remove
it like i said but if we refresh it's
actually deleted okay so the delete post
button is working so now in the single
post we can um we can start to we can
put that delete post button and it will
work as well
okay let's close this terminal and let's
uncomment the import of the single post
component and
uncommented the route let's save that
let's go back to our single post
so now now here at the bottom
right here after this button we can put
the delete button so we'll say if user
so the same stuff from
from single post
uh from postcard rather so if user and
user
dot username
equals
username
which is the username of the post
we'll say and and
we need to render our delete button
so you can say
delete
button and we're going to import it in a
second and we're going to pass it post
id equals id
oops
id like that
and let's close that
and let's go up here and we'll say
oh we didn't even import the like button
actually we need to import a bunch of
things here so we'll say import oops
import
like
button
from
go back one level to components slash
like button
and we can copy this one line paste it
one more time and ctrl d and say delete
button
and we need to import a bunch of things
from
semantic ui so we get the grid
the image the card
the button
okay so here we'll say
port
button
card
um
grid
image
from
semantic ui react
and let's save
okay so we need icon and label as well
so we'll say icon
and label let's save
all right so it says
post markup is assigned a value but
never used because we need to return it
we need to return something actually
some markup so here at the bottom we'll
say return
post markup
let's say all right says comment
comments is assigned a value but we're
not gonna worry about showing comments
right now
all right so let's look at our post all
right there we go so this is a post by
user
okay flux
this is a post by user
and we get the delete button so if we
click on that
okay so it deletes it
because
it actually deletes it but it doesn't we
need to redirect to the home page so you
see if i go to the home page that post
that was called another one is removed
so
the way we can do that
uh we can pass a call back to the delete
button
so here let's say callback
equals
and
let's call this delete oops
delete
button
callback let's be
let's be kind of uh or delete post
expressive with our
function naming so here up here
we can say function
delete post
callback
we say props dot
history
push
and we'll just go to the home page so we
got props so that should work and inside
the delete button
uh we need to take that call back so
here we'll
destructure as well callback
and
so right here actually in the update
once the uh
the post is deleted we need to call the
callback
okay but the problem with this actually
the callback might not we might not have
a callback so we can say
if callback
we call callback like that
because from the
postcard we don't actually have a
callback so
we'll do this if check
okay let's check that we have we have no
errors we don't
so if we go here go to this thanks guys
and we click on
delete and we click ok
there we go actually read our access to
the home page and is deleted because if
we refresh we see that it's actually
deleted
all right
let's now add this um
remove let's remove this post from the
cache once it's deleted so let's remove
this to do comment
and we need the proxy right now so we'll
from the update we'll take proxy
and we'll say we need that fetch posts
query
so here let's say
import
fetch
posts
query
from
actually what is that where is that util
slash graphql
ql if i can talk
so graphql like that
and uh right here
yeah right here before calling the
callback we'll say
uh like we did for the adding post we'll
say const
data equals
proxy dot
read query
and we'll pass a actually an object
oops an object
with the field query and that query will
be the fetch
post query
so now that we got the data we'll say
data dot get posts
and we'll say equals data
now we need to remove a post so we'll
say data
get posts
dot filter
so we want to keep all posts so we'll
say postwar
post.id we want to keep all posts that
don't have
the same id as this post id that we just
deleted
and we'll say proxy dot
write
query and here we'll say query is
fetch posts query
and the data is data like that
okay let's save
let's check out our app
let's post a new one
and now if i click delete and i confirm
there we go it's gone and uh
if we go to the single post page
well by the way the uh we can test the
like button so we can like and go back
to the home page and it's actually liked
so that's working from within this
component
so from uh from within this page we can
click delete post
it redirects us and it deletes the post
okay so that's it for this video
welcome back to class number nine in
this series
um in this one we're going to be adding
the comments on the single post page
and allowing users to post them and
delete them and all that good jazz
all right so let's get to it
okay let's go to our code codebase so
here in the single post
component i'm going to scroll down
actually here where this card ends still
inside of the column
we're gonna do the way we're gonna we're
gonna display them is i could put them
in a
component of their own but i don't see
any need in an application this small
so we already have comments out of this
um
thing like destructured from get post
which by the way is the reason why we
have a warning here because we're not
using comments but we're gonna use them
now
so here underneath the card we're going
to open an expression say comments
oops not comment count comments dot map
and for each comment
we're gonna oops not like that yeah like
that actually confuse myself
for age comment we're going to return
the following
so the comment is going to be a card of
its own
and yes we can nest cards
so let's give it the property of fluid
so it takes all the width
and here we'll give it a key of
comment dot id which is unique
so inside of the card we're gonna have a
card content so card content
and inside of here we're gonna have the
header so
card dot header
and this will be the username of the of
the person that commented so comment dot
username
like that
and underneath here we'll have the meta
card
dot meta which is when it was posted so
here we'll use moments to format it i
think we have yeah we have moments
because we formatted the date of the
post itself
so here we'll say moment oops moment
uh
moment with one m in the middle and here
we'll pass
comment
dot created
at
and we'll say dot from
now
like that
and here we'll have the card
description
kind of similar to the actually almost
the same as the actual post but this is
these are comments so here we'll say
comment dot body
all right let's save
let's make sure there's no errors there
shouldn't be any errors cool that
warning for comments is gone and if we
switch to our app
okay this one has no comments we can go
to this one has three comments and there
we go we get comments and uh
yeah i agree with this comment
okay so let's make it so that
um our comments we can delete and by the
way i need to log in here so i'll say
user
and the password is one through six
so let's go back to that one
where is it this one
so here uh since i'm the user i want to
be able to delete this comment
so let's go back to code and
i'm going to add the button right here
inside of the content so here we'll say
if user because we already have user
from the context
we say as well and
user.username
and equals
the comment
dot username which means i am or whoever
this user is is the owner of this
comment so we'll say and and we'll
render the following and we're actually
just going to render the delete button
and we'll pass it the post id
and which is the id and we'll pass it
the comment id
and uh i'll explain in a second which is
comment dot id
now what we're gonna do we're gonna go
to the delete button component so let's
go to the delete button
and here we're gonna make it so that
this can delete a post and it can delete
a comment as well and the way we're
going to do this we're going to make
this mutation right here dynamic
let's go down here
let's write the delete
comment mutation so i'll say const
delete
oops delete
yep that's spelled correctly
comment
mutation
this will be
gql
open template string and inside of here
we'll say
mutation
and delete
oops delete comment
and we'll pass it the post id
which is of type id and it's required
and here i need to put a
dollar sign
and here we'll say dollar sign comment
id
and this will be an id as well
and that's required
and here we'll say delete
comment
and we'll pass the post id
which is going to be the dollar sign
post id
and the comment id which is going to be
the dollar sign comment
oops id
i'll get the id
we get the comments
and get the from the comments we'll get
the id the username the created
ad
and the body of course
and here we'll say we need to get the
comment count
and yeah that's fine we can save
let's go up here
now here what we're going to do is
instead of just saying delete post
mutation here we're going to put another
variable we'll just call it mutation
like this
and this will be dynamic so we'll say
const mutation equals
and
here
here where we destructure post id let's
as well destructor um instructor
i can't talk guys sorry
so we'll destructure a comment id and
here what we need to say is comment id
uh we'll do a ternary operator so if we
want to delete um if you want to put
this button to delete a post we're just
going to give it a post id and a
callback or maybe not a callback and if
we want to delete the comment we're
going to give both of them so if we have
a comment id that means this button is a
on a comment and not on a post so we
want the uh delete actually no we want
the delete
comment mutation here if we do have a
comment id
else that means this button is on a post
so we want to use this mutation the
delete post mutation
now here we can change the function name
we don't have to but it's better if we
do and i'll call this delete post or
mutation because it can be either
and we'll do the same we'll say use
mutation or we'll pass this mutation
whichever one it is
and um
one thing we need to change by the way
here is let's wrap all of this let's cut
this and we'll say if
not
comment
id
do all of that
oops uh paste because if we're deleting
a comment we don't want to do this
because um
it automatically removes the comment and
we don't want to remove any posts from
our get posts but if we do delete a post
then we will not have a comment id then
this will execute and everything will
run just fine
and here in variables we need to also
pass the comment id
and by the way this is not a problem if
we're calling the delete post
mutation this will just be ignored in
that one and it will be null anyway
so here
uh i think everything is fine except
here we need to change delete post or
mutation right right there and let's
save this let's go back to our single
post save that
and let's look at our app
so there we go we get a button
and if we click it and we say okay there
we go it deletes the the comment and
with hopefully no errors
yes no errors cool
all right let's add a input here so that
if we're logged in we are able to post
uh comments to this post
all right let's go here actually right
here just above the comments we're gonna
say i'm going to open an expression and
say
if user
because we want to be able um we only
show the comment input if we're logged
in so if we use a if user render the
following and we'll have a card as well
here it's going to be fluid
and before we do any of this let's
create the
create comment mutation
so let's go down here
let's say const
let's call it um or submit makes more
sense
uh it doesn't matter this name but
so uh submit comment mutation
equals
gql
and here we'll say whoops
we'll say mutation
and it will take two things the post id
uh which is an id and that's required
and actually here a dollar sign
and here we'll take the body and that's
a string and that's required
inside of here we'll say create
comment
and we will pass a post id which is
going to be dollar sign post id
and here we'll pass a body which is
going to be dollar sign oops dollar sign
body
and we're going to get back
a post so here we'll get the id
because we need to get the id so that
apollo knows which post to update
and we need to get the comments because
that's what's been updated in this
object and we want to get id body
created
at
and username
all right inside of here we'll say
comment count
because that updates as well so we need
to get it back and update it
and yeah that's fine let's go
way up here underneath here we'll say
const and will this
array destructor the structure
submit comment from
use mutation and we got used mutation no
we don't let's get that
use
mutation from react polar hooks and here
we'll say mutation
and we'll pass the submit comment
mutation
and we're going to have a
an object here
i have an update function
or just a regular function an arrow
and here we'll uh what we need to do is
actually we need to as well create a
comment state variable so we'll say
const
and i'll have a comment
do we have your state actually we need
to use state
use state
and here we'll have a set
comment
whoops
equals use state
and the original state of the comment is
just an empty string
all right so
we want once we submit the comment we
want to empty the uh the input so here
we'll say set comment
back to an empty string and we need to
pass the variables for this mutation so
variables
is
this object with the post id
which is just this post id so we'll
leave that like that
and with the body of um comment
this one right here
there's something wrong here i'd put
double colon all right
that's fine so everything's fine here we
just go back to our mock-up here and we
actually add oops where is it
oh right here
oh yeah right here it closed itself
that's why it confused me
all right so here we'll close the card
here we'll have a form
actually before we need to to have like
a sort of paragraph that says post a
comment
and here we'll have a form
uh do we have form
yeah we don't so here we'll say
form
and let's go back down here inside the
form we'll have an input
um thing is i want to use form input but
there's a problem which i'll uh i'll
explain later why i'm using just the
regular material sorry not material ui
semantic ui
css i'll explain later so here we'll
just say div with a class
of
ui
action
input
oops input
and fluid
which is kind of like the equivalent of
using
field input or input or rather form
input
so here we'll have a traditional html
input
and here we'll have a type of
text
and a place oops place
holder
and we'll say comment dot dot i have a
name
we will say just comment like that
will have a value
which will be the state variable comment
we'll have an unchanged
on change
we can just inline it here we'll say
event we'll take an event the event and
we'll say set comment
to
event dot target dot value
like that
all right
let's close this input
and here we need a submit button so say
button
type
submit
and here we'll have a class name
of
uh ui
button
and teal for the color teal
and here we'll say disabled if
the comment
uh if there's no comment there's no
nothing written in the input field i
want this button to be so disabled to
not have to deal with the validation
so if comment.trim equals an empty
string then this button will be disabled
otherwise it will be enabled and it will
be clickable and if it's clicked we'll
say so we'll say on click
submit
comment
all right
here we'll say submit
all right that's gonna that should work
fine
it should trigger the submit comment
and that will send a submit comment
mutation with the variable comment which
has changed because we typed stuff
all right let's save this and let's make
sure there's no errors there isn't sweet
let's go back here
and
oh that looks weird
let me make sure
i got everything right
oh yeah because everything inside of a
card needs to be in a card content so
let's cut everything and say card
dot content it gives it that padding
amongst other things
let's paste everything back
save let's go back to our app there we
go that looks much better
now
if i write something now this is
clickable and if i press enter nothing
happens
all right let's uh inspect
so many errors
uh error code 400 response not
successful
let's check out what happened with the
actual
so let's go to apollo mutations and we
get this mutation
the body is okay and the post id is
correct
um
let's try to run this mutation
strange
post id
okay post id
variable post that is used expecting
type string really
uh let's go to our graphql
type definitions create comment oh i
made a mistake here post id instead of
putting that i'm expecting an id i put
i'm expecting a string well i'm not
going to change it here because for
those of you that are just doing the
react bit who will you'll be maybe
confused or something
i'm just gonna go to the
um this is just a patch by the way if in
an actual app i'm not gonna do this uh
fix like this i'm just gonna change this
actually not delete it's the create
comment or submit comment here i'm just
gonna take uh change the type to string
all right that work i mean that runs
let's go here if i type some
some random
comment and i click enter there we go
it's uh it's submitted and i get it here
and i can delete it and i can delete it
and if i keep typing comments it keeps
adding them without any problem and we
have no errors sweet
all right so there's one little problem
that bothers me is that once we type
something and we click enter this gets
emptied but this field is still um
active like kind of um i can still type
stuff i don't want it to do that i want
it to be kind of go back to this state
blurred
all right so
and this and here i can explain why i
did this approach where i just used an
input because now i can give it a
reference so we'll say ref equals
say comment
input
ref
because i can't give a reference to the
form input
component of a semantic ui react because
that's actually a react functional
component
all right so let's actually create this
reference let's copy that let's go to
the top
and right here underneath user we'll say
const comment input ref equals
use ref
and initially you'll just pass it the
value of null and we need to get user f
so here we'll say
use ref from react
and right here we're just going to say
actually
not here and the submit comment after we
set the comment to an empty comment
we're just going to say
the reference to that input dot current
dot blur
like this call it like a function like
that and that's going to blur the input
once we submit oops once we submit that
so
right here
uh yeah here i'll type a comment and
i'll submit it and there we go it
becomes the
like out of focus like blurred if i do
that again it blurs out the comment um
comment input
sweet i think that's it for this video
yeah let me check yeah that's it
all right sorry guys by the way if i'm
like kind of i sound less energetic and
excited about stuff i am excited but i'm
really really tired so
hello class welcome back
so this video is going to be one of two
last videos in the series um this one is
very going to be a very brief one where
we implement pop-ups and i'll explain
them in a second and in next one we're
going to have a deployment so we're
going to deploy both the back and then
the front end of our application to
heroku
so back to the pop-up thing so what i
noticed right now in our app is that
most of our buttons are just icon
buttons these buttons right here the
like the comment delete etc
the only problem with this is that
there's no text and some users might be
confused as to what this button does so
what we can do is um introduce these
tool tips these pop-ups that if you
hover over it tells you what this button
does of course you can do many other
things with them so the idea behind this
is to improve user experience and make
your app more
more easy to use and more
intuitive
so there's more complex implementations
of pop-ups for example this one right
here that shows info about the user
actually this could be a cool challenge
for you that you can implement where if
you hover over this image it tells you
since when this user has signed up or
you can show any other things and of
course this you can embed any html in it
you can
see here the
show your rating and there's some other
cool implementations um of the pop-up uh
for now we're just gonna use the basic
one to display some text so let's get to
that all right so let's go to our code
base oops now you my sql let's go to the
code base uh make sure both the server
and the client are running as per usual
i'm going to close this console
uh first i want to start with the
comment button so here i want to say
comment on post when i hover over it so
let's go to the postcard
and here
we're going to import pop up from
semantic ui react
and let's go
so the way it works is that you
basically wrap your um
your element that you want to
use as a trigger when you hover the
pop-up and you put this pop-up and you
put your element inside of the trigger
component or attribute and or prop
rather
and you have your content here which is
what the pop-up says
so let's go and actually apply this
so we have our
button here it's the comment uh button
so we can take all of this or actually
just type here say popup
and the
content
content
will say
um comment
oops
comment on post
and here we'll have a trigger which
triggers this and the trigger will be
all of this button right here so we can
just cut this and paste it here and
let's close this tag let's save to let
prettier format and let's have a look at
it so let's go to our app
so this is our comment button and there
we go we got our pop-up but i don't like
the white pop-up because our background
is already white so i'm going to use the
inverted
version of it to make it be black with
white text so we are right here we can
just add this prop inverted
and save
and go back
and there we go i think this is a better
contrast for our application all right
let's do the same for the like and the
delete buttons so
i'll start with the delete one so let's
go to delete button here
let's close that
so our button is right here
so we can just
we need to import popup from semantic ui
first so pop up
and here we can uh cut this button for
now
and here we'll say pop-up
and
we'll have content
and this will say delete
post
i have a trigger
and in the trigger we paste back our
button and of course we add inverted
to uh have it um be black all right
let's save
let's look at our delete button and
there we go it says delete post
um one problem with this though because
we're using the delete button for the
comments as well and it will still still
say delete post here while it should say
delete um
thing comment
we can make take a um
a message but for our use case we only
have two things so we can have a
conditional here so where are we right
here
in the content we can make it dynamic
and what we're going to do is we know if
we have a comment id that means we're
deleting a comment
a comment if we don't it's a post so we
can say
comment
id
so a ternary operator so if we have that
that means we're deleting a comment so
we'll say delete
comment
else that means we're deleting a post so
we'll say delete
post like this
save uh why is this
happening squiggly
oh sorry this um
this should go on the content my bad
not the inverted the inverted is just a
bullion prop
and here it says delete post and here it
says delete comment cool so that's
working
uh we'll do the same for the like now
one thing that i noticed is that we're
using inverted each time and we're kind
of typing the same thing and it's taken
multiple lines of code and we're going
to use it in multiple instances so we
can outsource this into its own
component
i mean maybe this is not the best use
case for this but this is just to show
you a good practice of how to outsource
these mini
elements that you have shared in
multiple places in your app so here
we'll create a new file in the util
folder and we'll call it my
popup call it whatever you want
so here
i'll say of course we need to import the
pop-up so we'll say import popup
from oops
from
semantic ui react
of course we need to react itself
here we'll have our function so function
my pop-up
i will take props
and it will return
the pop-up
and our pop-up is always inverted so
let's say invert it here
and we'll have content actually we can
destructure from the props so we want to
pass the content we can pass whatever we
want but we only need content for now
and we want to pass uh children
because that's where the trigger element
we need to pass an element for the
trigger prop so here the content will be
content from props from the props and
the trigger
will be
the children
so whatever that's inside of this
component
here of course we need to export
default
my
pop-up
save this
so let's go to the delete button
let's remove this import and here we'll
have our relative import so we'll say
import my popup
from go back one level to util slash my
pop-up
and here we replace pop-up with my
pop-up and the content will be the same
but we don't need to say inverted
anymore and this trigger stuff will be
in the children so here we'll have
actual content inside of our
um my popup element
and here we'll put our trigger stuff as
a child for this component
all right let's look at our app
let's refresh just in case and it still
functions the same
all right let's uh implement the same
for the
uh what is it the comment button so here
we'll remove the pop-up and actually you
can just copy this line from here
or from here
the import my pop-up
i would have typed it already if i
didn't just go to copy and paste it but
whatever so here we'll say my
pop-up
and here the content will be the same
it's static and we remove all that from
the trigger and
we put it inside
my pop-up here
paste
just to make sure that it's still
working
okay it's not working inside of here we
need to investigate this
so
oh yeah actually that's because it's
coming from the single post
that's a different um it's different
it's here it's from here so in the
single post
let's uh do the same import oops
actually i had a different thing in my
clipboard so here we'll say my pop-up
from
back to util to my pop-up
and let's look for that comment button
should be
yeah it's here so all of this so we can
just copy all of this button
and here we'll say
my
pop-up
and the content will be
the same as the other one so comment on
post
and the um doesn't have a trigger we
will just have content
child content inside of it
and there we go we have comment on post
so let's do the same for like let's go
to the
so that will be here
in the actual
in a postcard
or excuse me in the like button so here
we'll
import that
so import
my
pop-up
from
util slash my pop-up
or your pop-up
so here
this like button
we can just cut this let's say
my pop-up
and here the content as well is dynamic
because um it can be for liking or
unliking so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna say liked
and do a ternary so if it is liked the
tooltip will say unlike
unlike
else it will say um like
or you can put unlike post or like um
post it's up to you
all right so we paste back actually this
should should be in an expression in
curly braces and let's save
let's look at our app
there we go it says unlike and if i like
uh if i unlike it says like again cool
it's switching
hello class and welcome back to the last
class in this series where we deploy our
application and have it live on the
internet so i might have misled you in
the last class by saying that we're
going to deploy both the front end and
the back end on heroku we're not going
to do that we're going to deploy the
back end on heroku and the front end on
netlify which is something that i've
used on this channel before and i've
used for personal projects before it's
pretty cool it's really easy to start
with you just log in with your github
and literally like two clicks and you
deploy your front-end app
and
in terms of the back end we're going to
use heroku like i said it's really easy
as well to get started with i'm not sure
if it's to be honest if it's something
that people use a lot in production
personally i would use something like
aws or
even google cloud or what is known as
firebase uh but i don't know maybe they
have some good pricing you can check
that out for yourself but for us we're
just prototyping just you know it's a
hobby it's a project of passion i should
say all right so let's actually get
cracking okay first things first i
noticed that there are certain
things that need to be fixed about our
in our code base first is
i noticed that in the package json here
on the server there are certain um
dependencies that are for the client so
we need to move this to the client so
i'm going to do here on the
on this on the server level i'm going to
say
npm
uninstall
um
react
router
tom
semantic
ui
css
and semantic
ui oops
semantic
ui
react
so we need to move these can i copy from
here yeah i can copy from here okay so
we need to move this into the client so
i'm going to say cd client and say npm
install
and uh paste that in
and
that should be fixed
so
one other thing so in the index i
noticed here when we connected a
database uh we don't handle like we
don't catch an exception or an error if
it happens
that's not good because um
you know this can actually crash your
server and your app wouldn't even run at
all so here we're gonna say we're just
gonna say console.error
the error
uh it's not going to change a lot but we
catch the uh the error if it happens
16 000 vulnerabilities this this npm
order is getting out of hand anyway i'm
going to ignore this vulnerabilities
thing for now
um one more thing i want to change is
the
port
so where's the port
right here so it says 5000 it's a static
port but
in actual environments deployment
environments we could have like an
environment variable that holds the port
and we might need to use that instead so
i'm going to do i'm going to say here
const port equals
oops i'm going to take the environment
variable so we're going to say process
dot env and this is how you um access
environment variables uh port
like this
um or
so where's the ore right here the pipe
thing or 5000 meaning if this is null
we're going to get 5000 and here instead
of 5000 we're just going to say port
all right so that's fixed um
i think we're done with fixing stuff
all right so one thing that i'm going to
do we can actually deploy both of them
um like in one code base like the front
end and the back end but i've found
certain problems that happen on netlify
where if you have like a subdirectory
that contains actual app there are
certain shenanigans that we could avoid
by just separating the client and the
server to their own repositories i mean
it's better for separation of concerns
anyways so i'm gonna do i'm gonna go
back to my desktop so i'm gonna cd twice
i'm gonna create two files or folders
rather directories so make the i'm going
to say
mang
client and mug
server
cool so we have those repositories
uh let's go to our desktop actually i'm
going to open this
folder
so here i'm just i'm going to need the
stuff for the server so let's select
everything except for client and node
modules
uh copy that and then in the server um
yeah in the merge server here i'm going
to paste them and the client stuff
everything except the node modules and
paste the client stuff here oops paste
cool so we got the client stuff here and
the server stuff here
all right let's create let's start with
the server let's create a repository for
this
on github
so oops not here
let's go to
github
and here i'm going to create a new
repository
i can make it public or private doesn't
make a difference
so here i'm going to call it moong
actually i'm going to prefix it with
clast
i'll probably delete this because it's
not that
important people won't need this so i'm
going to say mung
server
and
i'm just going to create the repo
here i'm going to copy this i'll copy
the ssh one
it's the same but i think to push you
can't do the uh the https one so here
i'm going to open up
git bash in the server directory
i'm going to initialize the git repo
actually get in it
and here i'll say git add everything
get commit
oops if i can type
all right so get commit
i'm gonna say
oops just in it
i'm gonna now add the remote so i'm
gonna say get remote add
origin
and i'm gonna need to paste that origin
so here we're gonna double check say get
remote dash v there we go that origin is
added so we just now need to push the
code so we're gonna say get push
origin
master
all right so that's done so if we go
here we refresh
we see that our code is here
all right let's do the same for the
client and then deploy both of them so
let's create another repo
so here we'll say clast obviously you're
going to say something other than clast
if you want to say you can say that i
don't mind all right so here classed man
client
create repo
let's do the same thing grab this copy
it
and then go to the client
uh
open the terminal
and here we need to say get
in it
i don't know why i'm adding that flag
and
and here i'm going to say get add
everything
get commit
and i'm just gonna say init
and here we're gonna say get remote add
origin
and because i don't have this button
this like the inside button on my
keyboard i have to like right click and
put paste
here we're going to say get push origin
master
and the same thing will happen to this
repo for refresh
we get our client wait we don't we do we
do we get our client code here
cool all right let's deploy our server
code now so if we go to heroku actually
let's create an account
so sign up i've already done this but
i'm going to show you how to do this so
i'm going to put my name
i'm going to put my email my class email
so
gmail.com
company name not applicable professional
developer
united kingdom i'm gonna
this doesn't matter it's just for the
data collection stuff i'm just going to
say no just there
create free account
and i'm going to now go
in a side window and activate my account
gmail
there we go it says create new password
i'm going to create a new password
sweet click here to proceed
all right so now that we've set up with
an account um let's go back here
i want to go to the documentation so
documentation
uh first of all we need to install the
cli actually let's go to node and
yeah getting started with on heroku with
node
so here introduction
setup we need to install the heroku cli
so if you're on a mac you just run this
brew command you're on a linux you run
this sudo install but if you're on
windows like i am you just download this
installer so i'm going to
install it now yes
next next
and it's really simple you just install
the cli and then you do this heroku
login and uh it just opens up a
browser window where you confirm your
authorization and then that's it you're
logged in
i'm going to wait for it to install
all right so that's done close it
and i'm gonna close all this stuff here
i'm gonna open bash
so here i'm gonna say heroku
login
press any key to open the browser
all right log in
you are now logged in
i should be logged in now
how do i check actually
well
i think there's like a command to check
but i'm just gonna keep going i'm gonna
assume we're logged in yeah that says
i'm logged in cool
so stop that
and now we need to get our app started
now our app is already started we have
the app so i'm going to browse into it
so cd desktop
and i believe it's smart server yeah
server
all right so this is our app now we need
to push this to heroku so we go to
deploy the app so we're going to say
heroku create which creates an app now
there's a lot of options that you can
adjust here to change the name of the
app and a bunch of other stuff but i'm
just gonna go with the most basic uh
deployment right now
so in that repo here in the server we're
gonna say hiroku
create
boom so that's done
and now we're gonna say get push
heroku
master
so now that everything is pushed
okay so that's done
now um let's go check our app where do
we go actually
apps where's apps
or maybe in the command
so here it says that this is the app so
this is the endpoint for the app
and let's paste that
well it says error check logs
so i'm just going to run roku logs
okay now i know why because the npm
start is using a dependency like a
developer dependency i should have fixed
that which is nodemon and instead it
should just use the node index instead
of nodemon that's not available during
production so i'm just going to change
this to node index and
push this and hopefully that will fix it
actually i should change it in the other
in the other repo or in the other code
base so let me open this
and here i'm going to go to the
package.json and change this start to
just node index
now let's open the terminal get add
everything get commit
and here i'll say fixed start
script
here i'll push to origin
master
actually i need to push to heroku master
as well so get push
heroku master
all right so it's deploying that again
all right so let's check out our app
uh actually still deploying
it's gonna give us the um the base url
in a second there we go so let's
click this control click this
to open link
we'll wait for it
now obviously the performance on an
actual paid account will be better than
this you're not gonna have to wait this
much this is just a test account it's
just a free account just not charging us
anything yet
okay so that failed again and i checked
the logs again and i made a boo-boo and
it's uh right here so what is it
so process existed because
where's the error
yeah it's right here process failed to
point to port because actually
apparently port has to be um
all uppercase
so let's go here
let's make another change
this could have been way smoother
um so right here in the index.js
so it's here port is all caps like that
sorry about this guys but
in real
in real production things like this
happen all the time so maybe not cutting
them is actually giving you a better
um
a better like view of how things work in
the real world so here i'm just i'm not
even gonna push to
um to github i'm just going to push to
heroku master
so now it's going to deploy again
hopefully this time it works
[Music]
all right so let's control click this
base url and i guess third time is the
charm
all right so we get get query missing
but i believe this is just a like a um
because this is just our graphql server
i believe it's working so if we go to
postman open a new tab and here let's
send a request to this and as you
remember graphql stuff is always a post
request so let's go to the body we can
use this graphql
type of like body here
here let's actually send like a get
posts query
i'm just going to get the body
and the created at
and start that query
sweet we get 200 and we actually get all
of our data so our server has been
successfully deployed
let's actually now deploy the client
side of this
all right so i'm going to close this
close this
and let's go to
so here
oh obs go away so in the client
so let's open this
now i'm going to make a couple of
changes here as well so
in the package json uh
down
down here i'm going to add something
called a proxy because this is not on
the same server like as the actual
server
so i'm gonna this is actually not super
necessary but i'm gonna add it anyway so
the proxy will be the base url of our
app so here i'm just gonna copy that
and go back and put
here paste that
and we're going to change something else
so inside of our apollo provider the
base uri for our
api is that deployed app so we're going
to paste that here as well
so let's push these changes so i'm going
to open the terminal say get add
get commit
and edited
proxy and server
base url
let's push this
wait have i added the heroku here
actually no there is no heroku what am i
saying
all right so let's go to netlify
and here you can sign up or log in i'm
going to log in with my github account
i already have like an app here deployed
and here i'm going to deploy another one
so i'll say new site from git
and click github here
and it's going to now authorize my
github account or have authorized
netlife to access my repos
so
i believe i named it clast
monk
client
yes it's this one
and we need the master branch and yeah
we need to run actually this is all
correct because the eventually when you
build the app it's going to be in the
build directory
not in public actually so here we'll
just say deploy site
this will take some time you can click
here to see what's actually happening
behind the scenes in the deployment it's
just going to install all the
dependencies and build the app and then
serve it from that directory that was
specified which is the build directory
so i'm just going to wait for this to
finish and then carry on
sweet so that's deployed successfully
that's indicating by the indicated by
the green color
and we open our app and there we go so
we get all of our content that's being
served from our server and from our
database and we get the app and it's
fully functional so we can actually log
in here
if i haven't changed this password yeah
it's 136.
cool so we can log in we can post stuff
it's working exactly like it worked on
our machine guys so
yes so this video has been a bit rocky
has been a bit a bit of like errors i
could have cut all this these errors but
yeah this these things happen in the
real world so yeah maybe it's better
that i left them all right anyway thanks
for watching guys this series has been
exciting it's been uh sorry for the
delay for the last video and i hope
you've enjoyed it i hope you hope you've
learned a lot uh please let me know in
the comment sections any suggestions
anything you want to learn or anything
you want to
dig into i'll
happily make a video about it all right
thank you very much and i hope to see
you soon bye